Searchlight Pictures presents in the blink of an eye on Hulu on Disney Plus, a sweeping science fiction drama spanning the Stone Age, the present day, and the distant future, about the essence of what it means to be human, regardless of our place in history. The film is directed by Oscar-winning filmmaker Andrew Stanton and stars Rashida Jones, Kate McKinnon, and David Diggs. Stream in the blink of an eye now only on Hulu on Disney Plus. Sign up at Disneyplus.com. Hello everybody. Now we promise that we would be back with more news about the thrilling Rest is History Festival. And we can now reveal some more of the massive names who will be joining us at Hampton Court Palace on the 4th and 5th of July this year. One of them is the brilliant Tracy Borman who will be joining us to talk about the secrets of the Tudors. And the other, another massive fan favourite is Katia Hoyer, who will be talking about. her new work on Weimar, Germany. So I will be joined by Mary Beard to talk about what else Rome.
Searchlight Pictures 呈现《眨眼之间》，现已上线 Hulu 和 Disney Plus。这是一部横跨石器时代、现代和遥远未来的宏大科幻剧情片，探讨了无论身处历史何处，身为人类的本质意义。该片由奥斯卡获奖导演安德鲁·斯坦顿执导，拉什达·琼斯、凯特·麦金农和大卫·迪格斯主演。立即在 Hulu 和 Disney Plus 上观看《眨眼之间》。请前往 Disneyplus.com 注册。大家好。我们承诺过会带来更多关于激动人心的“历史余韵”节（Rest is History Festival）的消息。现在我们可以揭晓更多将参加今年 7 月 4 日和 5 日在汉普顿宫举办的活动的重磅嘉宾。其中一位是才华横溢的特蕾西·博曼，她将与我们探讨都铎王朝的秘密。另一位备受粉丝喜爱的嘉宾是卡蒂亚·霍耶，她将谈论她关于魏玛德国的新作。此外，玛丽·比尔德也将加入，与我们探讨罗马历史。
And I will also be joined by friend of the show, Ali and Sari, to talk about what else Persia. I will also be joined by massive fan favourite and Irish national treasure, Paul Rouse, who will be joining us to talk about the history of Ireland. And I will be joined by Helen Castor to talk about very appropriately, considering that we're at Hampton Court, Elizabeth I first. A few names left to announce and you'll be able to find the full lineup on the new Rest Is History website very soon. But Tom, the one thing that's puzzling me, how will our listeners be able to join us at this new festival? Well, Dominic, the answer is very simple. They will have to become members of the Rest Is History Club because this festival is exclusive to members of the Restless History Club.
节目老朋友阿里·安萨里也将加入，与我们探讨波斯历史。备受粉丝喜爱、被誉为爱尔兰国宝的保罗·劳斯也将参加，与我们探讨爱尔兰历史。海伦·卡斯托也将加入，考虑到我们身处汉普顿宫，她将非常应景地谈论伊丽莎白一世。还有几位嘉宾待公布，完整的阵容很快就会在全新的“历史余韵”网站上发布。但是，汤姆，有一件事让我很困惑，我们的听众该如何参加这个新节日呢？多米尼克，答案很简单。他们必须成为“历史余韵”俱乐部的会员，因为这个节日仅对俱乐部会员开放。
If you are a member, you can enter the ballot for two tickets. Now, you might think, I'd actually don't want to enter the ballot. I'd like guaranteed tickets. And the way to do that is to become an Afflestan, because if you're one of our Athelstan members, then you are guaranteed access to two tickets. So you are going to receive full details via email. And if you would like any extra information on the festival,
如果您是会员，就可以参加两张门票的抽签。现在，您可能会想，我不想参加抽签，我想要保证能买到票。实现这一点的办法就是成为“埃塞尔斯坦”会员，因为如果您是我们的一员，就能保证获得两张门票。详细信息将通过电子邮件发送给您。如果您想了解关于节日的任何额外信息，
on the ballot, on the guests, whatever, then click the link in the episode description. So for a chance to join us at the inaugural Rest Is History Festival, sign up to the club today at therestishistory.com because believe me, this is something that you won't want to miss. Have you ever climbed a mountain in full armour? Well, that's what we did. Pizarro going first the whole way up a tiny path into the clouds with drops sheer on both sides into nothing. For hours, we crept forward like blind men. The sweat freezing on our faces, lugging, skittery, leaking horses, and pricked all the time for the ambush that would tip us into death.
无论是关于抽签、嘉宾还是其他任何事，请点击剧集描述中的链接。想要有机会参加首届“历史余韵”节，请立即在 therestishistory.com 注册成为会员，相信我，这是您绝对不想错过的活动。你有没有试过穿着全套盔甲爬山？嗯，我们就是这么做的。皮萨罗一路走在最前面，沿着一条通往云端的小径，两侧都是深不见底的悬崖。几个小时里，我们像盲人一样向前摸索。汗水在我们脸上结冰，拖着受惊、渗血的马匹，时刻提防着可能将我们推向死亡的伏击。
Each turn of the path, it grew colder. The friendly trees of the forest dropped away. and there were only pines. Then they went two, and there just scrubby little bushes standing up in ice. All round us the rocks began to whine with cold, and always above us or below us, those filthy condor birds hanging on the air with great tasseled wings.
每转过一个弯，天气就越冷。森林里友好的树木消失了，只剩下松树。接着松树也没了，只剩下冰层中矗立的灌木丛。我们周围的岩石开始因寒冷而发出哀鸣，而我们头顶或脚下，总有那些肮脏的神鹫，扇动着巨大的流苏翅膀悬浮在空中。
Then night, we lay down twos and threes together on the path and hugged like lovers for warmth in that. burning cold and most cried. We got up with cold iron for bones and went on, four days like that groaning, not speaking the breath a blade in our lungs, four days slowly like flies on a wall, limping flies, dying flies, up an endless wall of rock. A tiny army lost in the creases of the moon. So that was Old Martin in Peter Schaffer's play The Royal Hunt of the Sun, which came out in 1964. I'm going to confess I had no idea really how to play him. I've tried out a range of tones and accents and voices.
到了晚上，我们两三个一组躺在小径上，像恋人一样紧紧相拥取暖，在那灼人的寒冷中，大多数人都哭了。我们拖着像冷铁一样的骨头起身继续前行，就这样呻吟着走了四天，一句话也不说，呼吸像肺里的刀片，四天里像墙上的苍蝇一样缓慢爬行，跛行的苍蝇，垂死的苍蝇，爬上一堵无尽的岩石墙。一支迷失在月球褶皱里的小小军队。以上是彼得·谢弗 1964 年的剧作《太阳的皇家狩猎》中老马丁的台词。我得承认，我真的不知道该怎么演他。我尝试了各种语调、口音和声音。
The voice changed from line to line, no? Yeah, I did. Dominant, I'm assuming that all the readings for the series are going to be coming from this play, are they? No, I don't think they are. No. Oh, because I thought that over the process of the six episodes we're doing, I could, maybe by episode six, I would finalise how old Martin should actually have spoken. Because his narrative stops too soon.
声音从一句台词变到下一句，对吧？是的，我变了。多米尼克，我假设这个系列的所有朗读都将来自这部剧，是吗？不，我不认为全是。哦，因为我以为在我们制作的六集节目中，我或许能在第六集之前确定老马丁到底应该怎么说话。因为他的叙述结束得太早了。
Oh, okay. Yeah, we'll have to find some other readings for the later episodes. Okay, so whatever one thinks of Old Martin and how he should be speaking, what he is doing there is describe the point in our story, where the Spanish conquistadors are inching their way through the Andes towards their showdown with the Inca Emperor at Hualpa. And Dominic, we've said it before. we're going to say it again, this is one of the most dramatic confrontations in history.
哦，好吧。是的，我们得为后面的剧集找些其他的朗读材料。好的，那么无论人们怎么看待老马丁以及他应该如何说话，他在这里描述的是我们故事中的那个时刻，西班牙征服者正艰难地穿过安第斯山脉，前往与印加皇帝阿塔瓦尔帕的决战。多米尼克，我们之前说过，还要再说一遍，这是历史上最戏剧性的对抗之一。
It is up there with Cortez meeting Moctezuma. It is that seismic. It is. It is an amazing scene in the play, actually. So it ends with the Spanish on the hillside above the town of Chiamauga, where they're due to meet at a whelper. And Martin says, you could almost touch the silence. Up on the hill, we could see the Inca's tents and the light from his fires ringing the valley. It's the sense of gathering tension and excitement.
它与科尔特斯会见蒙特祖马的场面不相上下。它是如此震撼。这确实是剧中一个令人惊叹的场景。它以西班牙人在卡哈马卡镇上方的山坡上结束，他们将在那里与阿塔瓦尔帕会面。马丁说，你几乎可以触碰到那种寂静。在山上，我们可以看到印加人的帐篷，以及环绕山谷的火光。这是一种紧张和兴奋感在积聚。
very, very dramatic moment. And that is the story we are telling today. So they're meeting with Atta Welper and what happens next. So let's just remind listeners where we got to. So the years 1532, the veteran conquistador Francisco Pizarro has landed in Peru with around 200 men looking for adventure, for glory and for gold. And he is convinced that somewhere south along the Pacific coast is this rich and sophisticated kingdom. And of course he is right. This kingdom is Tawantinsoyo, the land of the four quarters, or as we would call it, the Empire of the Inca's. One of the largest empires in the world at this point, from their heartland in Cusco, the Inca's ruled about 12 million people, all the way from Colombia and Ecuador in the north
非常、非常戏剧性的时刻。这就是我们今天要讲的故事。所以他们要与阿塔瓦尔帕会面，接下来会发生什么。让我们提醒听众我们讲到了哪里。那是 1532 年，老练的征服者弗朗西斯科·皮萨罗带着大约 200 人登陆秘鲁，寻找冒险、荣耀和黄金。他确信在太平洋沿岸南部的某个地方，有一个富裕而先进的王国。当然他是对的。这个王国就是“塔万廷苏尤”，即四方之地，或者我们称之为印加帝国。这是当时世界上最大的帝国之一，从库斯科的核心地带出发，印加人统治着约 1200 万人口，从北部的哥伦比亚和厄瓜多尔
to Chile in the south. Pizarro has made a stunning discovery. He's landed at a place called Tumbes, and he has discovered that the empire is in chaos. There's been ravaged by smallpox and by this fratricidal civil war between two claimants to the throne, Huasca, the older, brother, who is based in Cusco, and Atahualpa, the younger, who is formerly his viceroy in Quito in Ecuador. So a very Game of Throne-style struggle for the throne. And now Pizarro and his men. So that is his brothers, Hernando Gonzalo Arjuan, and his lieutenant, Ernando de Soto, great horseman, posh, but sinister, and short. They can see their opening.
一直延伸到南部的智利。皮萨罗有一个惊人的发现。他在一个叫通贝斯的地方登陆，发现帝国正处于混乱之中。它遭受了天花和两名王位争夺者之间手足相残的内战的蹂躏：身处库斯科的哥哥瓦斯卡尔，以及曾任他基多总督的弟弟阿塔瓦尔帕。这简直是一场《权力的游戏》式的王位争夺战。现在皮萨罗和他的手下——也就是他的兄弟埃尔南多、贡萨洛、胡安，以及他的副手埃尔南多·德·索托，一位伟大的骑手，时髦但阴险，而且个子不高——他们看到了机会。
If they can profit from the Inca's divisions, then maybe they can emulate Pizarro's cousin, Ernan Cortez, the conqueror of the Aztecs. So let's pick up the story from where we left off. It is midwinter, which means it's what we would call summer in Peru. Pizarro is still in the far north-western corner. He is about 900 miles north of modern-day Lima, so that is about 1,300 miles. north of Cusco, the Inca capital. Is there a road that goes straight there, though?
如果他们能利用印加人的分裂，也许就能效仿皮萨罗的表亲埃尔南·科尔特斯，那位阿兹特克人的征服者。那么，让我们从上次中断的地方继续讲起。现在是仲冬，这意味着在秘鲁是所谓的夏天。皮萨罗仍然在西北角。他距离现代利马以北约 900 英里，也就是距离印加首都库斯科以北约 1300 英里。不过，有一条直达那里的路吗？
No, a series of roads. The Incas have built this incredible road network. So it's actually not as far as it might sound. Well, it's still far, but it's... Yeah, but it's, you know, you don't have to hack your way through jungles or anything to get. No, there's not too much hacking, but there's a lot of crossing of rope bridges. And everyone knows that's dangerous. Fatiginous ascents and dissents and stuff like that.
不，是一系列道路。印加人建造了令人难以置信的道路网络。所以实际上并没有听起来那么远。嗯，还是很远，但是……是的，但是，你知道，你不需要在丛林里开路什么的就能到达。不，不需要太多开路，但有很多绳桥要过。大家都知道那很危险。还有令人疲惫的攀登和下降之类的。
Lama action. Exactly. But Pizarro wants to make sure that his governorship, that he has been awarded by, the Spanish king is on firm foundations. So the first thing he does is to establish a new town. This is from his cousin Cortez's Mexican playbook. This is what Cortez had done. You establish a town, you establish a municipal government, and that gives you the legal foundation that means you can't be challenged for governorship of this country. Can I ask you, Dominic, what has Charles the fifth licensed Pizarro to do? Is the notion that Pizarro will turn up, found a city,
羊驼行动。没错。但皮萨罗想确保他从西班牙国王那里获得的统治权有坚实的基础。所以他做的第一件事就是建立一个新城镇。这是他表亲科尔特斯的墨西哥剧本。科尔特斯就是这么做的。你建立一个城镇，建立一个市政政府，这就给了你法律基础，意味着你的统治权不会受到挑战。多米尼克，我可以问一下，查理五世授权皮萨罗做什么吗？皮萨罗的想法是直接出现，建立一个城市，
and that the Inca's will be so peaceable that they'll just go, that's great. And if they don't, is there a license to kind of attack them with horses and gunpowder and stuff? So as we will discover, under the regulations from I think 1513, the Council of Castile, you read in this thing called the requirement, which explains to them the history of the world, the story of Jesus and the fact that Charles V, the King of Spain, has been licensed by the Pope to export Christianity. to the Americas. When you read them this, they are legally bound to submit to Vasselage. And if they don't, you can kill them. So that essentially is the legal framework? Yes, exactly. But is
然后印加人会如此和平，以至于他们会说，那太棒了。如果他们不这样做，是否有授权可以用马匹和火药之类的东西攻击他们？正如我们将要发现的，根据 1513 年左右的规定，卡斯蒂利亚议会，你读过那个叫“要求书”的东西，它向他们解释了世界历史、耶稣的故事，以及西班牙国王查理五世已获得教皇授权，可以将基督教传播到美洲。当你向他们宣读这个时，他们在法律上有义务服从并成为附庸。如果他们不服从，你就可以杀死他们。所以这基本上就是法律框架？是的，完全正确。但是
is bizarro expecting that he's going to have to fight? Yeah, I'm sure he is. Or is he hoping that perhaps they could arrive at a mutually acceptable accommodation? I think ideally they'll reach an accommodation, but violence is always part of the Spanish repertoire. And everywhere the Spanish have been, so in the Caribbean, in Ivory Island, in Meso America, in Central America, everywhere they have been, theatrical terror has been an important part of their armory. I just wonder, they, because it is very punchy even by the stance of the Spanish, to invade an empire consisting of 12 million people with under 200 people. Yeah, it is. I mean, some people might say, you might say bonkers,
皮萨罗是否预料到他必须战斗？是的，我肯定他预料到了。或者他是否希望也许他们能达成一种双方都能接受的妥协？我认为理想情况下他们会达成妥协，但暴力始终是西班牙人的手段之一。无论西班牙人去过哪里，在加勒比海、在伊斯帕尼奥拉岛、在美洲中部，他们所到之处，戏剧性的恐怖一直是他们武器库中的重要组成部分。我只是觉得，即使以西班牙人的标准来看，用不到 200 人去入侵一个拥有 1200 万人口的帝国，也是非常大胆的。是的，确实。我的意思是，有些人可能会说，你可能会说这简直是疯了，
If it were not for the fact that we all know that they do it. I know. He's thinking he's going to get reinforcements, that they're going to arrive at any moment. Are the Spanish going to think of Atulper as a usurper? So does that invalidate him as someone with whom they can negotiate? No, I don't think so straight away. But I think the further they get, the more they realize the divisions of the Civil Wars are a wonderful, wonderful opportunity for them.
如果不是因为我们都知道他们确实做到了。我知道。他以为他会得到增援，以为他们随时会到达。西班牙人会把阿塔瓦尔帕视为篡位者吗？这是否会使他成为一个无法与之谈判的人？不，我不认为会立刻这样。但我认为他们走得越远，就越意识到内战的分裂对他们来说是一个绝佳、绝佳的机会。
Initially, they think of Atwalpa as a potential collaborator. Yeah, that's what they want, really. That's what all empires want. They don't want to fight unnecessarily. they may have to, but ideally everyone will collaborate with them. And in fact, the Spanish will find pensive people who collaborate with them in the Inca Empire, as they did with the Aztecs. It's kind of opportunistic militarism, then, is basically their mood. Yeah, I think that's the right way of putting it.
起初，他们认为阿塔瓦尔帕是一个潜在的合作者。是的，这确实是他们想要的。所有帝国想要的都是这个。他们不想进行不必要的战斗。他们可能不得不打，但理想情况下，每个人都会与他们合作。事实上，西班牙人会在印加帝国找到愿意与他们合作的人，就像他们在阿兹特克帝国所做的那样。那么，这基本上就是机会主义的军国主义。是的，我认为这样说很准确。
So Pizarro moves out on the 24th of September with his men. He's left some men behind to found this new town, San Miguel de Tangarada. And what that means is that he now has, what is it, 167 men plus him. So 61 horsemen, 106 infantry. And there's a brilliant book of historical detective work called The Men of Kayamaka by James Lockhart, American historian, in about 1970, where he really dug into where they were all from and what they all did. Most of them are from the poorer, more rural, western and southern parts of Spain to extra madura, you know, Andalutia and so on. They're quite young by and large. They're in their 20s.
所以皮萨罗在 9 月 24 日带着他的手下出发了。他留下了一些人去建立那个新城镇，圣米格尔·德·坦加拉拉。这意味着他现在有，是多少来着，167 人加上他自己。所以是 61 名骑兵，106 名步兵。有一本关于历史侦探工作的精彩著作，是美国历史学家詹姆斯·洛克哈特在 1970 年左右写的《卡哈马卡的人们》，他在书中深入挖掘了他们都来自哪里以及他们都做了什么。他们大多数人来自西班牙较贫穷、较偏远的西部和南部地区，埃斯特雷马杜拉、安达卢西亚等等。他们大体上都很年轻。他们大多在 20 多岁。
The more senior people are in their early 30s. So Pizarro, he's unusually old then. He's a real outlier. He's about 52, I would say. Yeah. These are not trained soldiers by and large. There's loads of accountants, tailors, merchants, craftsmen. There's a barber.
资历较深的人在 30 多岁出头。所以皮萨罗当时异常年长。他是一个真正的异类。我想他大约 52 岁。是的。这些人大多不是训练有素的士兵。里面有大量的会计、裁缝、商人、工匠。还有一个理发师。
There's a stone mason. These are people who basically were, they weren't the poorest of the poor. They were artisans, I guess, who have decided to, you know, seek a new life and a new fortune. There are some, aren't there? There's the Creighton guy, the artillery man. So it's good to have him on the scene. He's come with Pizarro and some guns. And Pizarro's brother, Hernando, who fought in Italy. So there's a couple of people with military experience. And a lot of these people will have seen action in the Caribbean. And that involved basically killing defenseless indigenous people, natives. That's the action that they're used to. They're not trained professional soldiers by any means. And why are they here? They are here really for money. Some of them are there for advice. venture. Some of them may be there for crusading zeal. You know, the Dominicans, for example. There are
还有一个石匠。这些人基本上是，他们不是最穷的穷人。我想他们是工匠，决定去寻找新的生活和新的财富。里面有一些人，不是吗？那个叫克雷顿的家伙，炮兵。所以有他在场很好。他是和皮萨罗一起来的，还带了一些枪。还有皮萨罗的兄弟埃尔南多，他在意大利打过仗。所以有几个人有军事经验。而且这些人中有很多在加勒比海见过战斗。那基本上涉及杀害手无寸铁的土著人、原住民。那是他们习惯的战斗。他们绝不是训练有素的职业士兵。他们为什么在这里？他们在这里真的是为了钱。有些人是为了冒险。有些人可能是为了十字军的狂热。你知道，比如多米尼克修士。有
five or six Dominicans who are with them. Yes, of course, Dr. Valverdey among them. Exactly. But there's a transactional element. When they've got their gold, they either settle down with a farm in Peru, or a lot of them will go back to Spain. That's the plan. So anyway, they set off 24th of September. It's a grueling, grueling trudge. So as one account puts it, there was much sun, little shade, much sand, and no water. Because this part of Peru is a kind of coastal desert plain. So they're making good time, about 14 miles a day. They're absolutely fascinated by what they see.
五六个多米尼克修士和他们在一起。是的，当然，瓦尔韦德博士也在其中。没错。但有一种交易的成分。当他们拿到黄金后，他们要么在秘鲁定居务农，要么很多人会回到西班牙。这就是计划。总之，他们在 9 月 24 日出发。这是一段极其艰苦的跋涉。正如一份记录所说，阳光充足，树荫很少，沙子很多，没有水。因为秘鲁的这一部分是一种沿海沙漠平原。所以他们进展顺利，每天大约 14 英里。他们对所见所闻感到非常着迷。
I mean, they write these fantastic accounts, the temples, the llamas, the very well-ordered roads and bridges, the storehouses of food by the roadside. I mean, that's a very good sign as far as they're concerned. Because that means there is a lot of order and civilization if there are sort of well-maintained storehouses. Do they note with surprise the lack of wheels? I think it becomes obvious why there's no. the wheels because there were no horses. And whenever they go, people shy away from the horses are absolutely astonished and horrified. A horse is a very frightening thing, I think, if you've
我的意思是，他们写下了这些精彩的记录，寺庙、羊驼、非常有序的道路和桥梁、路边的食物仓库。我的意思是，就他们而言，这是一个非常好的迹象。因为这意味着如果有一些维护良好的仓库，就说明这里有大量的秩序和文明。他们是否惊讶地注意到没有轮子？我想原因很明显，因为没有马。无论他们走到哪里，人们对马匹避之不及，感到非常震惊和恐惧。如果你从来没见过马，我想马是一种非常可怕的东西。
never seen a horse. And we know throughout the Americas, when the Spanish turned up with horses, people were absolutely stupefied and amazed and frightened. So they're beginning to attract attention. At one point, a messenger hails them on the road, and he says, I have been sent by Huasca, the defeated brother, by his faction at least. He has heard that you have come to bring justice to Peru, and he wants to ask for your protection. And Pizarro gives him a kind of non-committal answer. He says, where there's injustice, you know, we'll put it right,
我们知道在整个美洲，当西班牙人带着马出现时，人们都完全惊呆了、惊讶了，而且很害怕。所以他们开始引起注意。有一次，一名信使在路上拦住他们，他说，我是被瓦斯卡尔，那个战败的兄弟，至少是被他的派系派来的。他听说你们来秘鲁是为了伸张正义，他想请求你们的保护。皮萨罗给了他一个模棱两可的回答。他说，哪里有不公正，你知道，我们就会纠正它，
but nothing more than that. There's also a very weird incident quite early on, when the Spanish notice a kind of young man hanging around their camp and sort of lurking generally, and he's dressed as a sort of street peddler and he has this huge shawl that he wears over his head and shoulders to protect him from the sun
但仅此而已。在很早的时候还有一个非常奇怪的插曲，当时西班牙人注意到一个年轻人一直在他们的营地周围徘徊，通常是潜伏着，他打扮得像个街头小贩，头上和肩膀上披着一条巨大的披肩，用来遮挡阳光，
and he's always trying to get him to buy his trinkets and they call him Apu Apu is very interested in their horses and their swords and actually it turns out that Apu is a spy sent by Atta Welper. So not a very good one. Not a terribly good one, no. Now, I mentioned Atta Welper,
他总是试图让他们买他的小饰品，他们叫他阿普。阿普对他们的马和剑非常感兴趣，实际上事实证明阿普是阿塔瓦尔帕派来的间谍。所以不是一个很好的间谍。不是一个特别好的，不。现在，我提到了阿塔瓦尔帕，
what's he up to, the emperor? Or at least the would be emperor. He's been fighting his brother. He has made camp about 300 miles away in the mountains near the town of Kayamaka. His priority is not the Spanish. It is the civil war. So he's waiting for news from the south
他在做什么，皇帝？或者至少是准皇帝。他一直在和他的兄弟打仗。他在 300 英里外的山区，靠近卡哈马卡镇的地方扎营。他的首要任务不是西班牙人。而是内战。所以他在等待南方的消息，
where his commander, who has the excellent name of Kiskees, is leading the final assault on Kuzko. So when he gets news that a load of blokes with beards have turned up on the coast, they've been looting villages, they've been behaving poorly in storehouses, helping themselves to the food, they've been very rude to some of the locals.
在那里，他的指挥官，有着一个极好的名字叫基斯基斯，正在领导对库斯科的最后进攻。所以当他得到消息说，一群留着胡子的家伙出现在海岸上，他们一直在抢劫村庄，在仓库里表现得很糟糕，随意拿取食物，对一些当地人非常粗鲁，
he's perturbed, you know, what's all this, but he's not especially frightened. Apu reports back and says the Spanish are an absolute shambles, actually. Yeah, he says they're kind of villains, aren't they? Kind of indigence and robbers. Yeah, exactly. He says they're just an absolute bunch of rogues. Apu actually says, I think we should let them come, kill them all, except for three, because three of them are worth something.
他感到不安，你知道，这是怎么回事，但他并没有特别害怕。阿普报告说，西班牙人实际上是一团糟。是的，他说他们是那种恶棍，不是吗？那种流浪汉和强盗。是的，完全正确。他说他们绝对是一群无赖。阿普实际上说，我认为我们应该让他们过来，把他们全杀了，除了三个，因为其中三个有点用处。
They've got a blacksmith who makes swords, amazing swords. amazing swords. We should keep him. We should keep the guy who's the horse tamer because he can control these incredible beasts. And quite sweetly, he says we should keep the barber because he makes men look young again. Nice. By shaving them. By shaving them, presumably. So there are people in Peru who do have beards. I guess so. I don't know. I was thinking about this. Surely. And Ian's a clean shaven, surely, relatively clean shaven. I don't know. But I mean, because the whole stuff about bearded men coming. Yeah, exactly. It's important, isn't I suppose a Spanish beard is larger and bulkier than an Andean beard.
他们有一个铁匠，能制造剑，神奇的剑。神奇的剑。我们应该留下他。我们应该留下那个驯马师，因为他能控制这些不可思议的野兽。而且很可爱的是，他说我们应该留下那个理发师，因为他能让人看起来变年轻。不错。通过给他们刮胡子。通过给他们刮胡子，大概吧。所以秘鲁确实有人留胡子。我想是的。我不知道。我一直在想这个问题。肯定。印第安人是刮得干干净净的，肯定，相对刮得干干净净。我不知道。但我的意思是，因为关于留胡子的男人到来的整件事。是的，完全正确。这很重要，不是吗？我想西班牙人的胡子比安第斯人的胡子更大、更浓密。
An Andean beard? You never really would see an Andean beard particularly, would you? It's always about beards, isn't it, in history? Anyway, Atte Welp is entreat by all this, and he sends one of his senior officers called Sikin Chara to investigate. Confusingly, some chronicles say Sikin Chara is the same person as Apu, and some chronicles say he isn't. So, listeners can decide for themselves. The rich unknowability of history, isn't it? Of the past.
安第斯人的胡子？你从来不会真正看到安第斯人的胡子，对吧？历史总是关于胡子的，不是吗？总之，阿塔瓦尔帕对这一切很感兴趣，他派了他的一名高级军官，名叫西金查拉去调查。令人困惑的是，一些编年史说西金查拉和阿普是同一个人，而一些编年史说他不是。所以，听众可以自己判断。历史的丰富不可知性，不是吗？过去的。
Sikincharra, whether he's a person. poo or not, he arrives at this provincial capital called Kashas on the 10th of October and he finds that Anando de Soto, the dashing horseman, has already arrived with a scouting party. And who have we here? Now, unfortunately, Sassoto is behaving very poorly. So Kashas, this place, has a college attached to its sun temple. And the college houses 500 Ayayas, which are young women from noble families who are have been chosen for their bloodline or their beauty.
西金查拉，不管他是不是阿普，他在 10 月 10 日到达了这个叫卡哈斯的省会，他发现埃尔南多·德·索托，那位潇洒的骑手，已经带着侦察队到达了。我们这里有谁？现在，不幸的是，索托表现得很糟糕。所以卡哈斯这个地方，有一所附属其太阳神庙的学院。学院里住着 500 名阿克利亚，她们是来自贵族家庭的年轻女性，因为她们的血统或美貌而被选中。
And basically they will spend four years weaving cloth and brewing beer for the emperor. They're sort of virgins of the temple, I suppose. Vestal virgin equivalent. Exactly. Soto and his men have dragged them out into the square and are busy divvying them up among themselves. Sikin Chara is appalled when he sees this, but obviously he can't really do anything about it because he can't match the Spanish muscle.
基本上她们会花四年时间为皇帝织布和酿酒。她们算是神庙的处女，我想。相当于维斯塔贞女。没错。索托和他的手下把她们拖到广场上，正忙着在他们之间瓜分她们。西金查拉看到这一幕感到震惊，但显然他真的无能为力，因为他无法与西班牙人的武力抗衡。
He introduces himself to Soto. Soto says, great. when we're finished with his women, I'll take you back to Pizarro, which he does. They go back to Pizarro's camp. Sikincharra is very cool, actually, and we're told he entered as casually as if he'd been brought up all his life among Spaniards. This is because, of course, he's on home territory, and he's an important person, he's used to being treated with respect.
他向索托介绍了自己。索托说，太好了。等我们处理完这些女人，我就带你去见皮萨罗，他也确实这么做了。他们回到皮萨罗的营地。西金查拉实际上非常冷静，我们被告知他进入时就像在西班牙人中间生活了一辈子一样随意。这是因为，当然，他在自己的地盘上，而且他是一个重要人物，习惯了被尊重对待。
This leads me to believe, by the way, that he's not Apu, because if you'd been hanging around and ashore pretending to sell trinkets and then you return, you would look shame-faced, I think. But, I mean, not to do him down. I mean, he's obviously very, very cool. customer. You have to have incredible courage to turn up and confront these terrible men. He's brought them some nice gifts, though. He's brought them two pots that are shaped as forts, weirdly, and some skinned ducks. And the Spanish take the gifts, and it's amusing, actually.
顺便说一句，这让我相信他不是阿普，因为如果你一直在岸上徘徊，假装卖小饰品，然后你回来，我想你会看起来很羞愧。但是，我的意思是，不是要贬低他。我的意思是，他显然是一个非常、非常冷静的顾客。你必须有不可思议的勇气才能出现并面对这些可怕的人。不过他给他们带了一些精美的礼物。他带了两个形状像堡垒的罐子，很奇怪，还有一些剥了皮的鸭子。西班牙人收下了礼物，这实际上很有趣。
The Spanish are convinced themes must have some secret meaning or overthinking. So they're kind staring at the pot. They're massively overthinking at. They're like, did the pots mean? There were a lot of castles. And what about the ducks? They were skin. alive. That's what the Spanish say. They think that they're going to be skinned alive like the ducks. Actually, I think he's just giving them something to eat. Anyway, Sikin Chara spends two days in the camp. He makes a note of everything. And finally, he says to Pizarro, listen, the emperor would like you to continue to Chiamaka and he will grie you personally. And Pizarro is like, brilliant. This is what he wants. So he sends Sikin Chara back. He says, here's a lovely gift for the you and for
西班牙人确信这些东西一定有什么秘密含义，或者过度思考了。所以他们盯着罐子看。他们过度思考了。他们说，罐子意味着什么？有很多城堡。那鸭子呢？它们被活剥了皮。这就是西班牙人说的。他们认为他们会像鸭子一样被活剥皮。实际上，我认为他只是给他们一些吃的。总之，西金查拉在营地待了两天。他记下了所有事情。最后，他对皮萨罗说，听着，皇帝希望你继续前往卡哈马卡，他会亲自迎接你。皮萨罗说，太棒了。这就是他想要的。所以他把西金查拉送了回去。他说，这是给你和
the emperor, a nice linen shirt. We've got two glass goblets from Venice and some scissors. and some combs and a mirror. So back they go with the gifts. Now, important to say at this point, some people may be listening to this and thinking, do the Inca's believe that the Spaniards are gods, which is a thing you often hear as you do about the conquest of Mexico. There was absolutely no evidence for this whatsoever.
皇帝的一份可爱礼物，一件漂亮的亚麻衬衫。我们有两只来自威尼斯的玻璃高脚杯，还有一些剪刀、梳子和一面镜子。所以他们带着礼物回去了。现在，在这一点上很重要的一点是，有些人可能在听这个，心想，印加人是否相信西班牙人是神，这是你在谈论墨西哥征服时经常听到的事情。对此绝对没有任何证据。
The Inca's definitely didn't think they were gods. But they thought they might be, I mean, some Inca seem to have thought they might be messengers of the gods. So the Vera Koccha, the creator god, they call them, these are viracotchas. Yeah, Viracotas messengers or sons of Viracotta, exactly. And there is that kind of Quetzal-comatal stuff that you have in Mexico with the idea of bearded men coming from the sea and that these are veracotches. I'm not sure about that, Tom. I don't agree
印加人绝对不认为他们是神。但他们认为他们可能是，我的意思是，一些印加人似乎认为他们可能是神的信使。所以维拉科查，创造神，他们称他们为，这些是维拉科查。是的，维拉科查的信使或维拉科查的儿子，没错。而且在墨西哥有一种关于留胡子的男人从海上来，他们是维拉科查的说法，那种羽蛇神的说法。我不确定，汤姆。我不同意
with that. I think for a couple of reasons. First of all, I think people end up, even in the 16th century, conflating the two conquests and taking details from one and putting them in the other as the stories are repeated and written down by other chroniclers, by basically, it's that classic thing that historians do. The myths are repeated in secondary histories, and then people stop questioning them. But the thing about they are the sons of Viracotta or the messengers of Viracotta or whatever,
这一点。我认为有两个原因。首先，我认为人们最终，即使在 16 世纪，也会将两次征服混为一谈，并从一个征服中提取细节放入另一个中，因为故事被其他编年史家重复和记录，基本上，这是历史学家所做的经典事情。神话在次要历史中被重复，然后人们停止质疑它们。但是关于他们是维拉科查的儿子或维拉科查的信使之类的说法，
this is almost certainly either a literary formula or it's a courtesy. I don't think people think they are literally sent by the gods because the way the Inca's behave towards them is exactly as they would behave if they thought there were other human beings like themselves. Yeah, accepted. But just to kind of slightly push on this,
这几乎肯定要么是一个文学公式，要么是一种礼貌。我不认为人们认为他们真的是由神派来的，因为印加人对待他们的方式，完全就像他们对待其他像他们一样的人类一样。是的，接受。但只是稍微推进一下，
the Inca's are living among chaos. Their empire is being swept by plague. There is this terrible civil war. And now these peculiar people with mad animals have turned up. Yeah. Is there a sense of the kind of the Incan cosmology of different ages of cycles of time? And might this be presaging a new cycle of time?
印加人生活在混乱之中。他们的帝国正被瘟疫席卷。发生了这场可怕的内战。现在这些带着疯狂动物的奇特人出现了。是的。是否有一种关于不同时代、时间循环的印加宇宙观的感觉？这是否预示着一个新的时间循环？
a kind of apocalyptic sense. I think there is. I mean, there's definitely an apocalyptic there. There's definitely a strain. There were stories of the end of the world and things like that. But you don't get a massive sense that people think this is the end of days. These people are the heralds of some terrible doom, all of this kind of thing. I think actually most people are making much more pragmatic political considerations.
一种末日感。我认为有。我的意思是，绝对有一种末日感。绝对有一种压力。有关于世界末日之类的故事。但你并没有得到一种强烈的印象，认为人们认为这是末日。这些人是某种可怕厄运的先驱，所有这些事情。我认为实际上大多数人正在进行更务实的政治考量。
I mean, you can do both, can't you? Rather than apocalyptic or eschatological ones. We don't have really that much evidence of people thinking in apoconial. But we do have evidence about them making kind of Machiavellian calculations about what they can do with this new variable of 168 people with the horses in particular. I think that's what Atta Welper is doing, by the way. I think Attawelper is sitting there in Chiamarker. He's thinking about the Civil War. All the evidence actually for the next year or so is that that's pretty much all Attawelper is thinking about is the Civil War. I think he thinks
我的意思是，你可以两者兼顾，不是吗？而不是末日论或终末论的。我们并没有真正得到太多关于人们进行末日思考的证据。但我们确实有关于他们对这 168 个人，特别是带着马匹的新变量，进行马基雅维利式计算的证据。顺便说一句，我认为阿塔瓦尔帕正在做这件事。我认为阿塔瓦尔帕正坐在卡哈马卡。他在考虑内战。实际上，接下来一年左右的所有证据都表明，阿塔瓦尔帕考虑的几乎全是内战。我认为他认为
these will be excellent mercenaries. Or if he can kill him. them, get their horses, get the guy who can make the swords for him. Yes, of course. You know, it's literally a cutting edge, isn't it? Exactly. That, I think that's, I think their military technology really interests him and he thinks brilliant. I can use this to finish off Huascar's faction, complete my victory in the civil war.
这些人将是出色的雇佣兵。或者如果他能杀了他们，得到他们的马，得到那个能为他制造剑的人。是的，当然。你知道，这真的是尖端技术，不是吗？没错。我认为，我认为他们的军事技术确实让他很感兴趣，他想，太棒了。我可以利用这一点来消灭瓦斯卡尔的派系，完成我在内战中的胜利。
There's no reason for him to think this is an existential threat. The Spaniards, of course, know what happened in Mexico to Montezuma. He doesn't know. He's never heard of the Spaniards before. I mean, even at this stage, they are maybe. thinking, a decapitation strategy, you capture the top man, maybe some of his family, some of the elite, and then you leave the empire leaderless, it worked for Anne-Cortez, it worked for your cousin, Francisco, maybe it'll work for you.
他没有理由认为这是一个生存威胁。当然，西班牙人知道墨西哥发生了什么，蒙特祖马的遭遇。他不知道。他以前从未听说过西班牙人。我的意思是，即使在这个阶段，他们可能也在考虑，斩首策略，你俘虏了最高领导人，也许还有他的一些家人，一些精英，然后你让帝国群龙无首，这对埃尔南·科尔特斯有效，对你的表亲弗朗西斯科有效，也许对你也有效。
I guess that kind of, you know, capturing leading people is in the DNA of the Spanish. I mean, it's in the DNA of all Christians. I mean, all that 100 years of all stuff. Yeah. Capturing people and using that to get money is what European social. just do. Isn't it 1527? They invaded the Rome, sacked Rome, took the Pope prisoner. Thereby causing the English Reformation. Yeah. Exactly. So the Spanish are coming closer and closer just as old Martin describes in that reading from the play. They turn inland from the
我猜那种，你知道，俘虏领导人是西班牙人 DNA 中的一部分。我的意思是，这是所有基督徒 DNA 中的一部分。我的意思是，那 100 年的所有事情。是的。俘虏人并利用这一点来获取金钱是欧洲社会所做的。不是吗？1527 年？他们入侵了罗马，洗劫了罗马，俘虏了教皇。从而导致了英国宗教改革。是的。完全正确。所以西班牙人越来越近了，正如老马丁在剧中的那段朗读中所描述的那样。他们从
Pacific and they go up into the Andes. They go up through this valley through the cotton fields, into the canyons. They're now about 13,000 feet above sea level. So they're breathless, they're cold. It's absolutely freezing. There's no shelter. They're very, very anxious because they can see people watching them the whole time from kind of watch towers. I cannot imagine doing it. It's crazy. It just seems insane behavior. Anando Pizarro said, you know, they could have finished us off at any time.
太平洋转向内陆，进入安第斯山脉。他们上升到海拔约 13,000 英尺的地方。所以他们气喘吁吁，很冷。绝对冻僵了。没有遮蔽处。他们非常、非常焦虑，因为他们可以看到人们一直从某种瞭望塔上监视他们。我无法想象这样做。这太疯狂了。这看起来简直是疯狂的行为。埃尔南多·皮萨罗说，你知道，他们随时可以消灭我们。
We couldn't use the horses on the mountain roads. Off the roads, we could take neither horses nor foot soldiers. We were completely vulnerable snaking along these kind of mountain passes. And the incabs are watching us, but they're not acting. And actually we know from, well, we get a sense from later chronicles and things, that some of Atalpa's counsellors said, why are you letting these people come? Why not just strike now and kill them all? And Attaelper says to them, it is folly to be so concerned about 170 men. Let's find out who they are. What are we got to lose? Let them keep coming. He really wants to see the horses. He wants to see these guys who have strange weapons that make an explosion and everyone runs away. And it's a bit different from Montezuma. Montezuma was in his capital in the palace. Atta Welper is with his army. He's in a military camp with 80,000 men. Why would he be frightened about fewer than 200? He's just won a very bloody civil war. I mean, no one can be in any doubt that he's ready to crush his enemies if he has to. Right, exactly. On the 9th of November, they get another messenger from Atta Welper. The messenger brings them 10 lamas as a gift. And he's a He says, the emperor is at the hot springs near Kiamauga outside Kiyamauga. Their five days march away, he's looking forward to seeing you.
我们不能在山路上使用马匹。离开道路，我们既不能带马也不能带步兵。我们沿着这些山路蜿蜒前行，完全处于脆弱状态。印加人一直在监视我们，但他们没有采取行动。实际上，我们从，嗯，我们从后来的编年史等中得到了一种感觉，阿塔瓦尔帕的一些顾问说，你为什么要让这些人来？为什么不现在就出击把他们全杀了？阿塔瓦尔帕对他们说，为 170 个人如此担心是愚蠢的。让我们找出他们是谁。我们有什么可失去的？让他们继续来吧。他真的很想看看马。他想看看这些家伙，他们有奇怪的武器，会产生爆炸，每个人都跑开了。这和蒙特祖马有点不同。蒙特祖马在他的首都宫殿里。阿塔瓦尔帕和他的军队在一起。他在一个拥有 8 万人的军事营地里。他为什么要害怕不到 200 人？他刚刚赢得了一场非常血腥的内战。我的意思是，没有人会怀疑他如果必须的话，已经准备好粉碎他的敌人了。对，完全正确。11 月 9 日，他们收到了阿塔瓦尔帕的另一名信使。信使给他们带来了 10 只羊驼作为礼物。他说，皇帝在卡哈马卡附近的温泉，在卡哈马卡外面。他们还有五天的路程，他很期待见到你们。
They make slow progress, and five days later, they reached the last village before the Valley of Kaimarka, which is called Zavana. They've now been on the road for 52 days, six months in total since they left the coast because they've dalled at first. Another messenger brings them food from Atuelpa says he can't wait, looking forward to seeing you. And Pizarro says to his men, right, get ready for battle now. We're pretty close.
他们进展缓慢，五天后，他们到达了卡哈马卡谷前的最后一个村庄，叫扎瓦纳。他们已经在路上走了 52 天，从离开海岸算起总共六个月，因为他们起初耽搁了。另一名信使给他们带来了阿塔瓦尔帕的食物，说他等不及了，很期待见到你们。皮萨罗对他的手下说，好了，现在准备战斗。我们离得很近了。
So that's the 14th. The next day is the 15th. The path rises for the last time in the mountains, and they reach the highest pointed around midday. And they look down and they see the valley of Kiamauga. It's only a few miles wide. It's very fertile, fields of cotton plantations. They can see the stone buildings of the town glinting in the sunlight.
那是 14 号。第二天是 15 号。小径最后一次在山中上升，他们在中午左右到达了最高点。他们向下看，看到了卡哈马卡谷。它只有几英里宽。它非常肥沃，有棉花种植园的田野。他们可以看到镇上的石头建筑在阳光下闪闪发光。
And then beyond that, four miles behind the town, they can see this what looks like a sea of white shapes. And these are the tents of Attewell Pazami. tens of thousands strong. So to quote one of the conquistadors, so many tents were visible that we were filled with great apprehension. We never thought that Indians, his terminology in not mine, could maintain such a proud estate, nor have so many tents in such good order. It filled all of us Spaniards with fear and confusion, but it was not appropriate to show any fear, far less to turn back. And so Pizarro says, come on then, let's do this. And they spur their horses, and they're
然后在那之外，镇后四英里处，他们可以看到这看起来像是一片白色形状的海洋。这些就是阿塔瓦尔帕军队的帐篷。数以万计。所以引用其中一名征服者的话，可见的帐篷如此之多，以至于我们充满了极大的忧虑。我们从未想过印第安人（他的术语，不是我的）能维持如此骄傲的排场，也没有如此多的帐篷，秩序井然。这让我们所有西班牙人都充满了恐惧和困惑，但表现出任何恐惧，更不用说回头，都是不合适的。所以皮萨罗说，来吧，我们干吧。他们策马奔腾，
to descend the path towards the town of Kiamauga. God. So they approached the wall of Kiamauga. They go through the gate. Carmarka today is a very kind of handsome Spanish colonial town. At the time, it was an Inka town of about 2,000 people. And when they get there, there's hardly anybody there. The streets are deserted, quiet.
沿着小径向卡哈马卡镇下降。天哪。所以他们接近了卡哈马卡的城墙。他们穿过大门。今天的卡哈马卡是一个非常漂亮的西班牙殖民城镇。当时，它是一个拥有约 2000 人的印加城镇。当他们到达那里时，几乎没有人。街道荒凉、安静。
There are no people to be seen. One Spanish memoirist said later, all we could hear was the ghostly keening of women. singing of the death that awaits the strangers who have provoked the wrath of the great Inca. I mean, that's pretty terrifying. So they press on, they go past a sun temple, they go past another of these convents, and they emerge into this main square of Chiamarkham. Now, very important for people to get this into their heads.
看不到人。一位西班牙回忆录作者后来写道，我们能听到的只有妇女们幽灵般的哀号。歌唱着等待那些激怒了伟大印加王愤怒的陌生人的死亡。我的意思是，这太可怕了。所以他们继续前进，经过一座太阳神庙，经过另一座修道院，然后进入了卡哈马卡的主广场。现在，人们把这一点记在脑子里非常重要。
This square is surrounded on three sides by these kind of long, low stone buildings, which were basically, they're 200 yards long, and each of these buildings had about 20 doors in it. And basically what they were, they were called Kalankas, and they were used as dormitories for people who came through the town to work in the kind of labor gangs or in the army, or even pilgrims arriving for religious festival or something like that. They're there surrounded by these long, low buildings in the middle of this square. And there's no one else there. And it starts to rain. And they say, well, let's go into these buildings. And they go and take shelter in the barracks.
这个广场的三面被这些长而低的石头建筑包围，它们基本上，有 200 码长，这些建筑中的每一座都有大约 20 扇门。基本上它们是什么，它们被称为卡兰卡，被用作那些穿过城镇去劳工队或军队工作的人的宿舍，甚至是为宗教节日等而来的朝圣者。他们被广场中间这些长而低的建筑包围着。那里没有其他人。然后开始下雨了。他们说，好吧，让我们进这些建筑里去。他们就去营房里避雨了。
Dominant, also, can I just ask, in the middle of this square, there's a, kind of a ceremonial platform, isn't there? So that's also going to play a part. Exactly. So Pizarro and his captains gather around. They have for a little council of war. And they're all very nervous. You know, there's no one here. What's going on? I mean, how could you not be nervous? Of course. I'm not knocking them. That's the sound like you're judging them. I wouldn't be nervous. From the heart of the Cotswolds. Yeah. He sends his lieutenant, Anando de Soto, he says, I want you to go over to Attawell, go over to his camp, wherever he is. He's at these hot springs or whatever they are. Take 15 of your best horsemen. Take one of the
Dominant，还有，我能问一下吗，在这个广场中央，有一种类似礼仪平台的东西，对吧？所以那也会发挥作用。没错。所以皮萨罗和他的队长们聚集在一起。他们进行了一次小型的战争会议。他们都非常紧张。你知道，这里一个人也没有。到底发生了什么？我是说，你怎么可能不紧张呢？当然。我不是在批评他们。听起来你好像在评判他们。我可不会紧张。来自科茨沃尔德的中心地带。是的。他派出了他的副官阿南多·德·索托，他说，我要你去阿塔瓦尔帕那里，去他的营地，无论他在哪儿。他在那些温泉还是什么地方。带上你最好的15名骑兵。带上一个
interpreters with you. The Spanish can't agree, whether it's Felipe or Martineo. Don't they know the difference. Find out what he wants, what his plan is, you know, where does he want us to stay, all of this. Soto goes off with the cavalry, 15 men. And Francisco goes for a walk with his brother Anando. And Anando goes with him and says, I think we made a mistake, actually. You've just sent our best horsemen off to Atta Welper. But there's only 15 of them. And if the Inca's turn on them, you know, it's curtains for them.
翻译和你一起。西班牙人无法达成一致，到底是费利佩还是马丁内奥。他们难道不知道区别吗？弄清楚他想要什么，他的计划是什么，你知道，他想让我们待在哪里，所有这些。索托带着骑兵，15个人出发了。弗朗西斯科和他的兄弟阿南多去散步。阿南多和他一起走，说，我觉得我们其实犯了个错误。你刚刚把我们最好的骑兵派去阿塔瓦尔帕那里了。但他们只有15个人。如果印加人转而对付他们，你知道，他们就完蛋了。
And Francisco says, yeah, you're right, actually. You go after them. Take 20 more men and go after them. And Anando does. And that's very lucky for us and for everyone listening to this podcast, because among the men that Anando takes are people who wrote books about it afterwards. So there's a guy called Miguel de Estete and there's a guy called Diego de Trujillo. And they both wrote long Iowinnous accounts of the meeting,
弗朗西斯科说，是的，你说得对。你去追他们。再带20个人去追他们。阿南多照做了。这对我们和所有听这个播客的人来说非常幸运，因为阿南多带走的人中，有一些后来写了关于这件事的书。所以有一个叫米格尔·德·埃斯特特的人，还有一个叫迭戈·德·特鲁希略的人。他们两人都写了关于这次会面的冗长而生动的记录，
which of course, in traditional Spanish conquistula fashion, disagree with each other on the details. But anyway, so Anando is following Soto along the stone road, which goes out for four miles from the town to a place called Pulta Marka. Today it's called Banyos del Inca, the baths of the Inca, which tells you what it was like, because it's basically a spring. It's a spa. Attawalper is taking the waters there.
当然，按照传统的西班牙征服者风格，他们在细节上互不相让。但无论如何，阿南多沿着石路跟着索托，这条路从镇上延伸了四英里，通往一个叫普尔塔马卡的地方。今天它被称为印加浴场，这告诉你它是什么样子的，因为它基本上是一个泉水。它是一个水疗中心。阿塔瓦尔帕正在那里泡温泉。
And to get there, they have to go pass through Atowalper's army. It's all the tents. And Estete in his account says, you know, we were absolutely terrified, advancing through these ranks and ranks of soldiers who are just staring at us in silence. But having to kind of convey a sense of cool and fortitude. Yeah, of course. Imagine. It's like the bit in apocalypse now when they arrive at Marlon Brando's camp and all the tribesmen
为了到达那里，他们必须穿过阿塔瓦尔帕的军队。到处都是帐篷。埃斯特特在记录中说，你知道，我们当时非常恐惧，穿过这些一排排沉默地盯着我们的士兵。但必须表现出一种冷静和坚毅。是的，当然。想象一下。就像《现代启示录》里他们到达马龙·白兰度的营地，所有的部落成员
are just sort of staring at them silently. It's like that. And finally, they get through the camp and there's Attauilper's sort of palace building. his country house or whatever it is. This stone building with two towers and there's about 400 warriors guarding it and all they can hear is the water bubbling in the pipes and pools of the hot springs,
只是静静地盯着他们。就是那样。最后，他们穿过了营地，看到了阿塔瓦尔帕的宫殿建筑。他的乡间别墅还是什么。这座有两座塔的石建筑，大约有400名战士守卫着它，他们能听到的只有温泉管道和水池中冒泡的水声，
just this deathly silence. And their interpreter says we'd like to see the emperor and no one, you know, Atta well but doesn't come out. And Anando Pizarro, who's very hot-tempered, start shouting, tell that dog to come out. God, it's lucky they didn't speak Spanish.
只有这种死一般的寂静。他们的翻译说我们想见皇帝，但没有人，你知道，阿塔瓦尔帕没有出来。脾气暴躁的阿南多·皮萨罗开始大喊，叫那条狗出来。天哪，幸好他们不懂西班牙语。
Yeah. And eventually, a nobable, There are a nobleman appears, and it's their old mate, Sikincharra. And there's some form of interaction, very garbled, actually. And eventually the moment comes where they will see the emperor. Though what's unclear from the accounts is if they go in or Atalpa comes out, I think they go in, actually. Apu isn't around. Well, Apu may be Sikincharra.
是的。最终，一位贵族出现了，是他们的老朋友西金查拉。他们之间进行了一些互动，其实非常含糊。最终，他们见到皇帝的时刻到了。虽然记录中不清楚他们是进去了还是阿塔瓦尔帕出来了，我想他们其实是进去了。阿普不在。嗯，阿普可能是西金查拉。
This is the confusing thing. So, while all the accounts so garbled, this cuts to the confusion of the story. The Spaniards themselves are very confused because they don't really. really know what's going on. They don't speak a word of Ketua. They're in this new land. They might as well be on an alien planet. Weird people, weird customs, all this. And their interpreters are useless. So whoever is there, either Felipe or Martineo, they stumble and stutter, they must be frightened themselves. They're stumbling and stuttering over their words. And actually, when they do talk to Attawalpa, Attawapa at one point says, off the interpreter,
这就是令人困惑的地方。所以，虽然所有的记录都如此混乱，但这切中了故事的困惑之处。西班牙人自己也非常困惑，因为他们真的不知道发生了什么。他们一句克丘亚语都不会说。他们在这片新土地上。他们简直就像在外星行星上一样。奇怪的人，奇怪的习俗，所有这些。而他们的翻译毫无用处。所以无论谁在那里，费利佩还是马丁内奥，他们结结巴巴，他们自己肯定也很害怕。他们说话时磕磕绊绊。事实上，当他们和阿塔瓦尔帕交谈时，阿塔瓦尔帕有一次对翻译说，
what does this fellow mean stammering from one word to another and from one mistake to the next as if he were dumb? How do we know he said that? Because the interpreter must have translated. How can we trust the interpreter if they're useless? Well, I think it's highly unlikely you'd make that up about yourself. The emperor is saying that I'm a useless translator. You're not going to make that up.
这个家伙结结巴巴地从一个词说到另一个词，从一个错误犯到下一个错误，就好像他是个哑巴，这是什么意思？我们怎么知道他说了这些？因为翻译肯定翻译出来了。如果翻译没用，我们怎么能信任翻译呢？嗯，我认为你不太可能编造关于自己的事。皇帝说我是一个没用的翻译。你不会编造这种事的。
But anyway, throughout this story runs this thread of misunderstanding, possibly deliberate misinformation. In the Aztec story, listeners will recall that Melinchei, may well have been manipulating the whole thing. And we just don't know about these interpreters, these boys, whether they were making stuff up or whatever. Anyway, this is now the moment when they first lay eyes on the emperor. To quote one conquistador, he was seated on a small stool very low on the ground
但无论如何，贯穿这个故事的是误解的线索，可能是蓄意的错误信息。在阿兹特克的故事中，听众会记得梅林切可能一直在操纵整个事情。我们只是不知道这些翻译，这些男孩，他们是否在编造东西。无论如何，现在是他们第一次见到皇帝的时刻。引用一位征服者的话，他坐在地上一个很低的小凳子上，
as the Turks and moors are accustomed to sit, with all the majesty in the world, surrounded by all his women and with many chiefs near him. And they describe him, probably in his early 30s. He's got long black hair. He wears his hair long because he's been injured in the Civil War in the ear and he's covering that up. Oh, that's bad if you're a big ear, isn't it? Yes, I guess so, exactly.
就像土耳其人和摩尔人习惯坐的那样，带着世界上所有的威严，被他所有的妻妾和许多酋长包围着。他们描述他，可能在30岁出头。他留着长长的黑发。他留长发是因为他在内战中耳朵受了伤，他在掩盖这一点。哦，如果你耳朵很大，那很糟糕，对吧？是的，我想是的，确实。
So that's probably why he grows his hair. He has a brightly coloured cloak. He's got this thing on his brow, which is the crown, this circlet of red wool, threaded with gold and this kind of red tassel that hangs above his eyes. And this crown is called the mascapecha, which is the crown of the Sapa Inca. but he's sitting on the stool and he doesn't move. He doesn't even look at them. And they advance closer. Strangely, they're still on horseback. I don't quite know how this works, whether he's come out or they've gone in, but they're still on their horses because we are told Soto's horse was so close to Attawelper that the breath from its nostrils stirred the tassel. But still,
所以这可能就是他留长发的原因。他披着一件色彩鲜艳的斗篷。他额头上戴着那个东西，也就是王冠，这个红色的羊毛圆环，穿插着金线，还有那种垂在他眼睛上方的红色流苏。这个王冠被称为马斯卡佩查，是萨帕印加的王冠。但他坐在凳子上，一动不动。他甚至不看他们。他们走近了。奇怪的是，他们仍然骑在马上。我不太清楚这是怎么运作的，是他出来了还是他们进去了，但他们仍然骑在马上，因为我们被告知索托的马离阿塔瓦尔帕非常近，以至于它鼻孔里的气息吹动了流苏。但仍然，
Attawalpa doesn't show a flicker of emotion. Well, that speaks very well of his courage, doesn't it? Very well, because they're terrified of the horses. Toto takes a gold ring off his finger and he hands it to Atta whelper. And he says, with the translator speaking, he says, I give you this as a token of peace and friendship. Atta Welper puts out his hand. He takes the ring, but he still won't meet Soto's eye and he doesn't show a flicker of emotion. And Soto then gives a prepared speech. He says, I come on behalf of the mighty king, King Charles.
阿塔瓦尔帕没有表现出一丝情绪。嗯，这很能说明他的勇气，不是吗？非常好，因为他们害怕马。索托从手指上取下一枚金戒指，递给阿塔瓦尔帕。他说，在翻译的传达下，他说，我给你这个作为和平与友谊的象征。阿塔瓦尔帕伸出手。他拿过戒指，但他仍然不看索托的眼睛，也没有表现出一丝情绪。然后索托发表了一篇准备好的演讲。他说，我代表强大的国王，查理国王而来。
He has appointed Francisco Pizarro as governor of these lands. And Pizarro would be absolutely thrilled if you would come and see him in the town. Atalpa says nothing, and he still doesn't raise his eyes. And one of his nobleman speaks up through the interpreter and says, you know, the Sapa Inca is not going to be going anywhere. This is the last day of his ritual fast in celebration of his victory in the war. And he will not be accompanying you. And Anando Pizarro at this point completely loses patience.
他任命弗朗西斯科·皮萨罗为这些土地的总督。如果阁下能去镇上见他，皮萨罗会非常高兴的。阿塔瓦尔帕什么也没说，他仍然没有抬起眼睛。他的一位贵族通过翻译开口说，你知道，萨帕印加哪里也不会去。这是他为庆祝战争胜利而进行的仪式性斋戒的最后一天。他不会陪你们去的。阿南多·皮萨罗此时完全失去了耐心。
And he says, well, for God's sake, man, when you look at us or whatever, He shouts at Atta whelper. And now for the first time Attawalper raises his eyes to meet them. His eyes are blazing with fury. They are implacable. And they are, if they could be cold and blazing, they're both blazing and cold. And his eyes meet theirs. And now, at last, he speaks.
他说，看在上帝的份上，伙计，当你看着我们或者什么的，他对着阿塔瓦尔帕大喊。现在阿塔瓦尔帕第一次抬起眼睛看着他们。他的眼睛里燃烧着愤怒。它们是不可调和的。而且它们是，如果它们能既冷酷又燃烧，它们既燃烧又冰冷。他的眼睛与他们的目光相遇。现在，终于，他开口了。
Are you leaving us on that cliffhanger? On that, yeah. Oh, my God. Unbearable tension. Well, we're better going to have a break and listen to some adverts or something. Unless, of course, you'll remember of the rest of history club. Anyway, we will be back to find out what Atada Welper has to say to the Spaniards. This episode is brought to you by Claude, by Anthropic.
你要把我们留在那个悬念中吗？在那一点上，是的。哦，天哪。难以忍受的紧张。好吧，我们最好休息一下，听听广告什么的。除非，当然，你是历史俱乐部的成员。无论如何，我们会回来的，看看阿塔瓦尔帕对西班牙人说了什么。本集由Anthropic的Claude赞助。
Now, history lives in the contradictions. Yeah, I've always been fascinated by the great mysteries of history. Like, what happened to the Maya civilization of Central America? Why were all those great cities deserted? But Tom, there's one mystery that's all. fascinated you, isn't there? Yes, Dominic. I've always been fascinated by the question of how humans came to make and use fire. How did that originate? And a tremendous discovery was announced just last year that the place where it seems fire was invented was Suffolk. Well, do you know,
现在，历史存在于矛盾之中。是的，我一直对历史上的伟大谜团着迷。比如，中美洲的玛雅文明发生了什么？为什么那些伟大的城市被遗弃了？但是汤姆，有一个谜团一直让你着迷，不是吗？是的，多米尼克。我一直对人类是如何制造和使用火的问题着迷。那是怎么起源的？去年宣布了一个巨大的发现，火似乎是在萨福克发明的。嗯，你知道，
one of the things that makes history so fascinating is the kind of back and forth between sources to try and explain these great mysteries. And you know what's built for that kind of thinking? Claude is built for that way of thinking. It doesn't smooth things over. It helps you dig into the disagreement to reveal something new. Anthropic just committed to not running adverts in Claude. So your thinking stays yours. Try Claude for free at clod.a.ai slash rest is history. Hello everybody and welcome to the book club, a new podcast from Gollhanger. Hosted by me, Dominic Sambrook. And me, Tabitha Siread.
让历史如此迷人的一件事是来源之间的来回推敲，试图解释这些伟大的谜团。你知道什么适合那种思考吗？Claude就是为那种思维方式而构建的。它不会掩盖问题。它帮助你深入挖掘分歧，揭示新的东西。Anthropic刚刚承诺不在Claude中投放广告。所以你的思考仍然是你自己的。在clod.a.ai/rest is history免费试用Claude。大家好，欢迎来到读书俱乐部，这是Gollhanger推出的一个新播客。由我，多米尼克·桑布鲁克主持。还有我，塔比莎·西里德。
As some of you may know, I've been Dominic's producer on The Rest's History. And we even did a mini-series last year about all things books. And since we enjoyed that so much, we have decided to roll it out as its own show. So it'll be coming out every Tuesday. We'll be doing a different book each time and digging into all the stories behind them. And we are going to be talking about the historical contexts behind some of the greatest and most famous books of all time. We're going to be digging into the remarkable people behind them, the unexpected stories behind the stories, and also unraveling the plot of each book a bit and delving into the depths of the story.
正如你们中的一些人可能知道的，我一直是多米尼克在《历史的其余部分》的制作人。去年我们甚至做了一个关于书籍的迷你系列。因为我们非常喜欢，所以我们决定把它作为一个独立的节目推出。所以它会每周二播出。我们每次会讨论一本书，深入挖掘背后的所有故事。我们将讨论一些有史以来最伟大、最著名书籍背后的历史背景。我们将深入挖掘它们背后非凡的人物，故事背后的意外故事，也会稍微梳理一下每本书的情节，深入探讨故事的深度。
Now, you don't have to have read the books to listen to the show, but we hope that by the end of each episode, you will be able to pretend to people that you've read them. That is the key thing. And either way, whether you read them or not, we hope that you'll learn lots of fascinating facts, you'll do lots of great stories, and maybe Tabby, the odd laugh. We will be looking at thrilling, gothic bodice rippers like Wuthering Heights and Frankenstein, as well as iconic stories like The Great Gatsby or Little Women. And then also some more modern stuff.
现在，你不必读过这些书也能听这个节目，但我们希望在每一集结束时，你都能假装读过它们。这是关键。无论如何，无论你是否读过，我们希望你能学到很多迷人的事实，你会听到很多伟大的故事，也许塔比，还会偶尔笑一笑。我们将关注惊险的哥特式言情小说，如《呼啸山庄》和《弗兰肯斯坦》，以及像《了不起的盖茨比》或《小妇人》这样的标志性故事。然后还有一些更现代的东西。
So Game of Thrones, Normal People, The Hunger Games, Hamlet, all manner of exciting stories. So please join us on our journey into all things books, wherever you get your podcasts. Just search for The Book Club every Tuesday and hopefully we will see you there. You don't need AI agents, which may sound weird coming from Service Now, the leader in AI agents. The truth is, AI agents need you.
所以《权力的游戏》、《正常人》、《饥饿游戏》、《哈姆雷特》，各种令人兴奋的故事。所以请加入我们的书籍之旅，无论你在哪里获取播客。每周二搜索《读书俱乐部》，希望我们能在那里见到你。你不需要AI代理，这听起来可能很奇怪，来自Service Now，AI代理的领导者。事实是，AI代理需要你。
Sure, they'll process, predict, even get work done autonomously. But they don't dream, read a room, rally a team, and they certainly don't have shower thoughts, pivotal hallway chats, or big ideas. People do.
当然，它们会处理、预测，甚至自主完成工作。但它们不会做梦，不会察言观色，不会团结团队，它们肯定没有洗澡时的灵感、关键的走廊谈话或伟大的想法。人会。
And people, when given the best AI platform, they're freed up to do the fulfilling work they want to do. To see how ServiceNow puts AI to work for people, visit ServiceNow. Hello, everyone. Welcome back to The Rest is History. It is the 15th of November 1532. We are outside the town of Kamaka and Anando de Soto and Anando Pizarro are face to face with the emperor of the Inca's the redoubtable, terrifying Attawalper with his, what was it, Dominic, his blazing and ice cold eyes. Yeah. And so there's been a very tense standoff and now Attawalper has raised. those blazing and ice-cold eyes to meet the eyes of the Spaniards. He's about to speak. And Dominic, what does he say? Nothing good. He says, I've heard complaints about you from my men in the north. My captain in San Miguel sent to tell me that you've treated the chiefs badly and threw them into chains.
当人们拥有最好的AI平台时，他们就被解放出来去做他们想做的充实工作。要了解ServiceNow如何将AI为人类服务，请访问ServiceNow。大家好，欢迎回到《历史的其余部分》。现在是1532年11月15日。我们在卡哈马卡镇外，阿南多·德·索托和阿南多·皮萨罗正与印加皇帝面对面，那位令人敬畏、可怕的阿塔瓦尔帕，带着他的，是什么来着，多米尼克，他那燃烧又冰冷的眼睛。是的。所以发生了一场非常紧张的对峙，现在阿塔瓦尔帕抬起了那些燃烧又冰冷的眼睛，与西班牙人的目光相遇。他正要开口。多米尼克，他说了什么？没什么好话。他说，我从北方的部下那里听到了关于你们的抱怨。我在圣米格尔的队长派人告诉我，你们对待酋长很糟糕，把他们关进了铁链。
And he sent me an iron collar. He says that he killed three Christians and one horse. And Anando Pizarro now does all the talking. And he is a very undiplomatic man. He says, your men in San Miguel were women. They were no better than women. One horse was enough to conquer the whole land. And when you see us fight, you will know what kind of men we are. And Attau Elper then says, and this goes back to something you were saying in the first half-ton. He says, I could have stopped you coming, but I chose not to. I know you are the sons of Viracoccha. You are messengers from our God king, Pachucati. Your coming was foretold by my father, Hwena Capac. So I gave orders that nobody. was to stop or harm you. But you think this is fabricated by a Spaniard who is muddling it up with what Moctezuma had said to Cortez, do you? Or do you think this is authentically what he might have said? I think there are multiple explanations of this. So one of them is he genuinely thinks they're messengers from the god king, Patrick Goody. I think this is extremely unlikely. Nothing that Attawelper does. If he genuinely thought that, would he not have met their eyes earlier?
他给我送来了一个铁项圈。他说他杀了三个基督徒和一匹马。阿南多·皮萨罗现在负责所有的谈话。他是一个非常不懂外交的人。他说，你们在圣米格尔的人是女人。他们和女人没什么两样。一匹马就足以征服整个土地。当你看到我们战斗时，你就会知道我们是什么样的人。然后阿塔瓦尔帕说，这回到了你在上半场提到的事情，汤姆。他说，我本可以阻止你们到来，但我选择了不这样做。我知道你们是维拉科查的儿子。你们是我们神王帕查库蒂的信使。我的父亲瓦伊纳·卡帕克预言了你们的到来。所以我下令任何人不得阻止或伤害你们。但你认为这是西班牙人编造的，把它和蒙特祖马对科尔特斯说的话混淆了吗？还是你认为这确实是他可能说的话？我认为这有多种解释。其中之一是，他真的认为他们是神王帕查库蒂的信使。我认为这极不可能。阿塔瓦尔帕所做的一切。如果他真的那样想，他难道不会早点与他们对视吗？
Would he not be a bit more polite? I think, of course, he would have behaved. differently if he genuinely thought that. So I think there are two possibilities. One is that this is a literary flourish and that, you know, this has now become the formula. That when you write a chronicle of Spanish conquest of somewhere in the Americas, the king greets you with these kinds of words and this is what the reader's like. Number two is, he does say this. Actually, I think number two is probably right. He probably does say something a bit like this and it's a courtesy. I would have said so too because, I mean, who or what is viriculture to the Spaniards? Yeah. I mean, they don't care.
他难道不会更礼貌一点吗？我想，如果他真的那样想，他当然会表现得不同。所以我认为有两种可能性。一种是这是一种文学修辞，你知道，这已经成为了一种公式。当你写关于西班牙征服美洲某地的编年史时，国王会用这种话来迎接你，这就是读者喜欢的。第二种是，他确实说了这些。实际上，我认为第二种可能是对的。他可能确实说了类似这样的话，这是一种礼貌。我也会这么说，因为，我是说，维拉科查对西班牙人来说是谁或什么？是的。我是说，他们不在乎。
It might be embellished or whatever. I think it's a little bit like, to borrow what the great historian Matthew Restle said about when this happened in Mexico, he said it's a little bit like, it's an exaggerated version of when someone comes to your house and you say, oh, do what you like, you know, fete comche-vous, you know, relax and joy.
这可能是润色过的什么的。我认为这有点像，借用伟大的历史学家马修·雷斯特尔关于这在墨西哥发生时所说的话，他说这有点像，当有人来到你家时，你说，哦，随便做，你知道，请自便，放松享受，这是一种夸张的说法。
You don't really mean it. You don't mean do whatever you like. You say, you know, flowery things to make people feel welcome. And this is what Atta Welper is doing. Anyway, when he does something, this. Anando moderates his tone. And he says, my brother, the governor, they always call Francisco Pizarro, the governor. The governor loves you dearly. If you have any enemies, we will send horsemen to deal with them for you. With ten horsemen, we could defeat all your enemies.
你并不是真的那样想。你不是说做任何你想做的事。你说，你知道，华丽的话语让人们感到受欢迎。这就是阿塔瓦尔帕正在做的。无论如何，当他做这件事时。阿南多缓和了他的语气。他说，我的兄弟，总督，他们总是称弗朗西斯科·皮萨罗为总督。总督非常爱你。如果你有任何敌人，我们会派骑兵为你处理他们。有十名骑兵，我们就能击败你所有的敌人。
Your own men will only be needed to mop up the people who run away. And Anando says this to Atualpa, and Atalpa just gives this cold smile. Anando himself, we wrote a memoir of it, recalls. he smiled as someone who did not think much of us. Of course, Attau'alpa may be very excited by this deep down because he may be thinking, you know, these horses were a big deal. And I could really finish off my brother's faction with these horses. And of course, he doesn't need the Spaniards to ride them in the laurel. Exactly.
你的人只需要负责清理那些逃跑的人。阿南多对阿塔瓦尔帕说了这些，阿塔瓦尔帕只是冷笑了一下。阿南多自己，我们写了一份回忆录，回忆道。他笑了，就像一个不把我们放在眼里的人。当然，阿塔瓦尔帕内心可能对此非常兴奋，因为他可能在想，你知道，这些马是一件大事。我真的可以用这些马消灭我兄弟的派系。当然，他不需要西班牙人骑着它们去劳雷尔。没错。
He says, Atoalpa now says, will you dine with me? And they say, no. We have to go back. He says, will you like drinks? I'll get women to bring them jugs of this beer, this chicha. And then the sun is setting, and Attawelpa, says, would you like to stay the night? And Anando says, no, we'd like to go back to our friends in the town in Kiamauga. And Attaelpa says, okay, you can stay in these barracks around the town square.
他说，阿塔瓦尔帕现在说，你要和我一起用餐吗？他们说，不。我们必须回去。他说，你们想要饮料吗？我会让女人们拿来这种啤酒，这种奇查酒。然后太阳下山了，阿塔瓦尔帕说，你们想留下来过夜吗？阿南多说，不，我们想回到我们在卡哈马卡镇的朋友那里。阿塔瓦尔帕说，好吧，你们可以待在镇广场周围的这些营房里。
Brilliant. And then he says, I'll see you tomorrow. Tomorrow I'll come into Kaia Marka to meet your leader. But there's one more moment before they leave. Atalpa clearly fascinated by the horses. So Anando de Soto, dressage champion of Spain, gives him a little riding demonstration. He wheels around, on this horse, we're told that Atta Welper was amazed and amazed at seeing the agility with which it wheeled. But the common people showed even greater admiration. There was much whispering. So there's clearly a little crowd. One squadron of troops drew back when they saw the horse coming towards them. And there's actually a dark side to this story. So when the Spanish had gone, Atta Welper says, those soldiers who drew back, ran them all up, please, and execute them
太棒了。然后他说，明天见。明天我会进卡哈马卡去见你们的领袖。但在他们离开之前还有最后一个时刻。阿塔瓦尔帕显然对马很着迷。所以西班牙盛装舞步冠军阿南多·德·索托给了他一个小小的骑术表演。他在马背上转圈，我们被告知阿塔瓦尔帕对看到它转圈的敏捷性感到惊讶。但普通民众表现出了更大的钦佩。有很多窃窃私语。所以显然有一小群人。当他们看到马向他们冲来时，一个中队的士兵退缩了。这个故事其实有一个黑暗面。所以当西班牙人走后，阿塔瓦尔帕说，那些退缩的士兵，把他们都抓起来，请处决他们
because they showed fear and we can't show fear at the strangers animals and some sources say he said find their wives and children and kill them too I want to make sure
因为他们表现出了恐惧，我们不能对陌生人的动物表现出恐惧，有些来源说他说找到他们的妻子和孩子，把他们也杀了，我想确保
that nobody does this again and that we don't show the slightest flicker of fear when we see the Spaniards horses so end the bloodline of these cowards exactly
没有人再这样做，当我们看到西班牙人的马时，我们不会表现出一丝恐惧，所以结束这些懦夫的血统，没错
you said that with real relish Tom I could see you saying that actually if one of our producers showed fear of a horse I think that'd have been a good Inca. So nightfalls in Kayamaka, but the Spanish can't sleep. So Pizarro has a young cousin called Pedro who acted as his page, and Pedro described a
你带着真正的快感说了那句话，汤姆，我能看到你这么说，实际上，如果我们的制作人对马表现出恐惧，我想那会是一个很好的印加人。所以夜幕降临在卡哈马卡，但西班牙人无法入睡。所以皮萨罗有一个年轻的表弟叫佩德罗，他担任他的侍从，佩德罗描述了
council of war in Pizarro's quarters. We took many views and opinions among ourselves about what should be done. All were full of fear, for we were so few and so deep in the land where we could not be reinforced. Of course, let's remind ourselves, there are 160, eight of them. They are thousands of miles from help. There are several million people between them and the coast. And they are basically up against 80,000 Inca's camped in the tents just outside the town. So quite a tight corner. It's, yeah, the odds are against them, I think it's reasonable to say.
皮萨罗营房里的战争会议。我们在我们中间就应该做什么采取了许多观点和意见。所有人都充满了恐惧，因为我们太少了，而且深入这片土地，无法得到增援。当然，让我们提醒自己，他们有168人。他们离救援有几千英里远。在他们和海岸之间有几百万人。他们基本上是在对抗驻扎在镇外帐篷里的8万印加人。所以处境非常艰难。是的，胜算对他们不利，我认为说这是合理的。
And Pizarro encourages his men, says, come on, we've got this. We can do this. And one of the chronicles says, you know, that night, he went around and he said, you know, every man a night. Every man is a knight. It's very like the kingdom of heaven, if you've seen that film, the Orlando Bloom Crusades film, where at the end, he knights everybody in the defense of this city. So even though he's saying all this, they must be thinking, Jesus, this is going to be tough. So the question is, what will they do when morning comes, when Attawelper turns up? Now, some Spanish chroniclers said later, Pizarro is hoping that Attawalpa will submit, will agree to accept Charles V, that's overlord, and Jesus is the master of all.
皮萨罗鼓励他的部下，说，来吧，我们能做到。我们可以做到。其中一部编年史说，你知道，那天晚上，他走来走去说，你知道，每个人都是骑士。每个人都是骑士。这很像《天国王朝》，如果你看过那部电影，奥兰多·布鲁姆主演的十字军电影，最后他在保卫这座城市时封了所有人为骑士。所以即使他说了所有这些，他们一定在想，天哪，这会很艰难。所以问题是，当早晨到来，当阿塔瓦尔帕出现时，他们会做什么？现在，一些西班牙编年史家后来写道，皮萨罗希望阿塔瓦尔帕会投降，会同意接受查尔斯五世，也就是霸主，耶稣是万物的主宰。
I think this is highly unlikely that Pizarro thought that would actually happen. I mean, he'd be mad if he thought that would happen. I think he was always going to use some form of violence. He knew what his cousin Cortez had done in Mexico. And as Matthew Restle says in his excellent books about the Spanish conquest of the Americas, standard practice was theatrical terror. You strike first. You use surprise.
我认为皮萨罗认为这真的会发生是极不可能的。我是说，如果他认为这会发生，他就是疯了。我认为他总是会使用某种形式的暴力。他知道他的表弟科尔特斯在墨西哥做了什么。正如马修·雷斯特尔在他关于西班牙征服美洲的优秀书籍中所说，标准的做法是戏剧性的恐怖。你先发制人。你使用突袭。
You use your military technology, which is your horses, your swords and so on. And your guns. Yeah, and your guns. and you hope that that will prevail. You can frighten people into acquiescing. And so this is what Pizarro says to his men. He says, look, we're going to take advantage to the geography. When Aso Elper and his men arrive, we'll allow them to filter into the main square.
你使用你的军事技术，也就是你的马、剑等等。还有你的枪。是的，还有你的枪。你希望这能占上风。你可以恐吓人们让他们默许。所以这就是皮萨罗对他的部下所说的。他说，看，我们要利用地理优势。当阿塔瓦尔帕和他的部下到达时，我们会让他们进入主广场。
Whereas you rightly said, Tom, there's a platform in the middle. And Ato Elper will probably go up onto the platform or something like that. We'll see. Now, meanwhile, we will be in the barracks, which are on three sides of the square. Everyone will wait for my signal to burst out of the doorways. On two sides we'll have most of the horses under Soto and my brother Hernando and the other big cheeses
正如你正确指出的，汤姆，中间有一个平台。阿塔瓦尔帕可能会走上平台什么的。我们会看到的。现在，同时，我们将待在广场三面的营房里。每个人都会等我的信号冲出门外。在两边，我们将有大部分骑兵，由索托和我兄弟埃尔南多以及其他大人物带领
and they can deal with the Inca troops On the third side I'll be there with a smaller group of people And our job is to snatch at a welper And as for the rest of the men And we're not talking about huge numbers You hide in the alleys around the square When the fighting starts
他们可以对付印加军队。在第三边，我会带着一小群人。我们的任务是抓住阿塔瓦尔帕。至于剩下的人，我们谈论的不是庞大的数字，你们躲在广场周围的小巷里。当战斗开始时
Try to seal off the square And that will mean that the Inca's can't escape And they'll be the mercy of our cavalry And as for the signal, when Atta whelper has taken his place in the centre of the square, Pedro de Candia, the guy from Crete, the artilleryman, he can fire his guns, blow a load of trumpets. And when you hear that, it's game on and we'll do this. And Pedro de Candia is on this raised platform. Yes, he is.
试着封锁广场，这意味着印加人无法逃脱，他们将任由我们的骑兵宰割。至于信号，当阿塔瓦尔帕在广场中央就位时，来自克里特岛的炮手佩德罗·德·坎迪亚可以开火，吹响大量的号角。当你听到那个信号时，比赛就开始了，我们会做到的。佩德罗·德·坎迪亚就在这个高台上。是的，他就在那里。
He's on the platform. So kind of relatively speaking, commanding heights. Exactly right. Now, Miguel de Estete, who's one of the memoirists, described the mood after their meeting, broke up and darkness drew him. Few slept and we kept watching the square from which the campfires of the Indian army could be seen. It was a terrible sight. Most of them were on a hillside and close to one another. It looked like a brilliantly star-studded sky. So they're kind of looking out at these campfires, these tents and they're absolutely, the Spanish, you know, they're absolutely
他在平台上。所以相对而言，占据了制高点。完全正确。现在，米格尔·德·埃斯特特，回忆录作者之一，描述了他们的会面结束后，黑暗降临时的心情。很少有人睡觉，我们一直盯着广场，从那里可以看到印加军队的营火。那是一个可怕的景象。他们大多数人在山坡上，彼此靠近。看起来像一片星光灿烂的天空。所以他们有点看着这些营火，这些帐篷，他们绝对，西班牙人，你知道，他们绝对
terrified. So the hours passed, they don't get much sleep. Dawn breaks the 16th of November 1532. Attawalpa's ritual fast is over. He and his closest friends have been drinking to mark the end of the fast. He's in no hurry to go anywhere, actually. Probably got a bit of a hangover. So all morning the Spanish wait, their Dominicans have held mass. Everything is ready.
恐惧。所以时间流逝，他们没怎么睡。1532年11月16日黎明破晓。阿塔瓦尔帕的仪式性斋戒结束了。他和最亲密的朋友一直在喝酒以庆祝斋戒结束。他其实并不急着去任何地方。可能有点宿醉。所以整个上午西班牙人都在等待，他们的多米尼加人举行了弥撒。一切都准备好了。
The tension, you know, mounting all the time. A messenger arrives mid-morning from Attawalpa's camp and he says, Atta whop is still coming. He's coming with his men, and his men will be armed. Pizarro says, fine, you can come however he likes. I will welcome him as a friend and a brother. That's nice. Another hour goes by, no one comes.
紧张感，你知道，一直在增加。上午中期，阿塔瓦尔帕的营地来了一名信使，他说，阿塔瓦尔帕还在来。他带着他的部下，他的部下会携带武器。皮萨罗说，好，他想怎么来都行。我会像朋友和兄弟一样欢迎他。那很好。又过了一个小时，没有人来。
Then another messenger arrives, and he says, actually, they've changed their mind. They're going to leave their weapons behind. And why is that, do you think? I genuinely don't know. I think it never really occurs to Attawalper that he need the weapons. He's got so many men. Yeah, I suppose. Got so many men.
然后又来了一名信使，他说，其实，他们改变主意了。他们要把武器留在后面。你认为这是为什么？我真的不知道。我认为阿塔瓦尔帕从来没觉得他需要武器。他有那么多人。是的，我想也是。有那么多人。
I mean, the Spanish would be mad to attack him. Just thinks, highly, 168 men against 80,000. I mean, you'd never do that. Still, they don't come, though. At midday, there's movement in Atu Elper's camp, and the Spanish lookouts say, the entire plane is full of men. Now, Pizarre's men have all taken their places
我是说，西班牙人攻击他简直是疯了。只是认为，高度，168人对抗8万人。我是说，你永远不会那样做。尽管如此，他们还是没来。中午，阿塔瓦尔帕的营地有动静，西班牙哨兵说，整个平原上都是人。现在，皮萨罗的部下都各就各位
in the barracks and then hiding and whatnot, and you can imagine how nervous they are now. Pedro Pizarro said, I saw many Spaniards urinate without noticing it out of pure terror. So the Inca's start to advance towards the town. And I quote, they all wore large gold and silver discs like crowns on their heads. They were apparently all coming in their ceremonial clothes with a livery of checkered colours like a chessboard. And as they march, the Inkers are kind of doing this motion to sweep the ground, as if clearing rubbish off the ground or something.
在营房里，躲藏着什么的，你可以想象他们现在有多紧张。佩德罗·皮萨罗说，我看到许多西班牙人因为纯粹的恐惧而不知不觉地尿了裤子。所以印加人开始向镇上推进。我引用，他们都戴着巨大的金银圆盘，像王冠一样戴在头上。他们显然都穿着礼服，穿着像棋盘一样的格子颜色。当他们行进时，印加人有点在做这种扫地的动作，好像在清理地上的垃圾什么的。
And they're singing a song, which the Spanish. don't understand, but one of them said it was by no means lacking grace for those of us who heard it. Half a mile outside the town, the Inca's stop, and Pizarro can't believe it. He sends out an interpreter, why have you stopped? Natoalpa's men say, well, we've been told to halt. It's mid-afternoon now, and the emperor has decided he'd like to spend the night outside the city and come in tomorrow. And Pizarro is horrified by that. He doesn't want the Inca's right outside the town overnight, because the one thing the Spanish are dreading is a night attack. And he sends another Spaniard to go and implore Atalpa, please come and visit us before nightfall.
他们唱着一首歌，西班牙人听不懂，但其中一个人说，对于我们这些听到的人来说，它一点也不缺乏优雅。在镇外半英里处，印加人停了下来，皮萨罗简直不敢相信。他派出一名翻译，你们为什么停下来？阿塔瓦尔帕的部下说，嗯，我们被告知要停下。现在是下午中期了，皇帝决定他想在城外过夜，明天再进去。皮萨罗对此感到恐惧。他不希望印加人在镇外过夜，因为西班牙人最担心的一件事就是夜袭。他派了另一名西班牙人去恳求阿塔瓦尔帕，请在天黑前来看望我们。
You know, we won't harm you, we won't hurt you. You can come without fear. A slightly weird thing to say, why would Atta Welper be frightened? There's no reason for him to be afraid. The Spanish rather giving themselves away there, I think. They are, aren't they? Yeah. I mean, it's betraying their secret thoughts.
你知道，我们不会伤害你，我们不会伤害你。你可以毫无恐惧地来。这话说得有点奇怪，为什么阿塔瓦尔帕会害怕？他没有理由害怕。西班牙人在这里有点暴露了自己，我想。他们是，不是吗？是的。我是说，这背叛了他们内心的想法。
It is. Exactly, it is. Anyway, the sun is beginning to sink and at last Atalpa moves. He advances now with about 6,000 men leaving most of his army outside the town. His men, as they promised, they've left there as a way, the heavier weapons behind. They've got slings, they've got stones, and they've got little axes, maybe kind of ceremonial axes almost. They come through the gate, they come along the street. At last they enter the central square.
确实。没错，确实。无论如何，太阳开始下沉，阿塔瓦尔帕终于动了。他现在带着大约6000人前进，把大部分军队留在了镇外。正如他们承诺的那样，他的部下把较重的武器留在了后面。他们有投石索，他们有石头，他们有小斧头，几乎是某种礼仪斧头。他们穿过大门，沿着街道走。终于，他们进入了中央广场。
The vanguard, then the emperor's party. them wearing these big feathered headdresses and stuff. And Attauilpa himself, he is sitting and I quote, on a very fine litter lined with feathers of many colours and embellished with plates of gold and silver. Eighty lords carried him on their shoulders, all wearing a very rich blue livery. He was seated on the litter on a small stool with a rich saddle cushion, very richly dressed, with his crown on his head and a collar of large emeralds around his neck. Very like Montezuma on the causeway being brought out to me, Anne and Cortez. I mean, it is amazing how many parallels between those two stories there are.
先锋队，然后是皇帝的随从。他们戴着这些巨大的羽毛头饰什么的。阿塔瓦尔帕本人，他坐着，我引用，在一顶非常精致的轿子上，衬着许多颜色的羽毛，并装饰着金银板。八十位领主用肩膀抬着他，都穿着非常华丽的蓝色制服。他坐在轿子上的一个小凳子上，垫着华丽的马鞍垫，穿着非常华丽，头上戴着王冠，脖子上戴着一串大祖母绿项链。非常像蒙特祖马在堤道上被带出来见我和科尔特斯。我是说，这两个故事之间有这么多相似之处，真是太神奇了。
It is, isn't it? I agree completely. You do wonder, did it actually happen? Or are the two accounts bleeding into one another? They're not making it up, but... Yeah, I think the two accounts do bleed into each other a bit. Actually, I think that's what makes it quite hard to discern the truth. That said, there are enough Spanish accounts of this incident.
是啊，不是吗？我完全同意。你确实会想，这真的发生了吗？还是这两个记录在相互融合？他们不是在编造，但是……是的，我认为这两个记录确实有点融合在一起。实际上，我认为这使得很难辨别真相。话虽如此，关于这次事件的西班牙记录足够多。
Of course. For us not to doubt it. And the example of what Cortez did with Moctezuma is obviously an inspiration here. Completely. So the sun has now almost set. There are thousands of Inca's in the square. Atta Welper signals from the litter, and he's raised up high above people's heads, and one of his captain steps forward with his personal standard,
当然。让我们不怀疑它。科尔特斯对蒙特祖马所做的事情的例子显然是这里的灵感来源。完全是。所以太阳现在几乎落山了。广场上有成千上万的印加人。阿塔瓦尔帕从轿子上发出信号，他被高高举起，超过了人们的头顶，他的一位队长带着他的个人旗帜走上前，
as if to claim this kind of central platform. Now, what is Attauelper thinking at this moment? Everything we know of him is that he is a very ruthless and proud, and, if necessary, violent man. I don't think he senses any danger. I think he thinks the Spanish are shambles and are undisciplined. I think his plan is that, At some point this evening, he will take Pizarro prisoner.
仿佛要宣称这个中央平台。现在，阿塔瓦尔帕此时在想什么？我们所知道的一切关于他的是，他是一个非常无情和骄傲，如果必要的话，暴力的人。我不认为他感觉到了任何危险。我认为他认为西班牙人是一团糟，而且纪律涣散。我认为他的计划是，今天晚上某个时候，他会把皮萨罗抓起来。
Possibly he will kill him. Possibly he will kill the Spaniards. But what he wants are the horses to use in his war. What he doesn't expect is that the Spaniards won't be there. And he calls out in Quechua, where are they? You know, where are you? And two Spaniards come out of one of these barracks. One of them is a guy called Enando Dladana, who had learned a little Quechua.
可能他会杀了他。可能他会杀了西班牙人。但他想要的是那些马，以便在战争中使用。他没料到的是西班牙人不会在那里。他用克丘亚语大喊，他们在哪里？你知道，你们在哪里？两个西班牙人从这些营房里走出来。其中一个是叫埃南多·德拉达纳的人，他学了一点克丘亚语。
So he could work as a, he could help with the interpreting. And the other is the Dominican friar Vicente de Valverde. Great to have a Valverde back on the show. And he is with one of these interpreters, either Martineo or Philippio. And he is holding a cross in one hand and a prayer book in the other. And he advances towards Atta Welper. And there are different accounts, very confusing accounts of what happened next. But here is, I think, a way through.
所以他可以作为，他可以帮忙翻译。另一个是多米尼加修士文森特·德·瓦尔韦德。很高兴瓦尔韦德又回到了节目中。他带着其中一名翻译，马丁内奥或费利佩。他一只手拿着十字架，另一只手拿着祈祷书。他向阿塔瓦尔帕走去。关于接下来发生的事情有不同的记录，非常混乱的记录。但这里是，我认为，一种理清思路的方法。
Valverde kicks off by saying to Attaelper, would you like to, to come inside and have dinner with Francisco Pizarro. And this is obviously a ploy to get him apart from his men. And Attau Alpa says, no. And Attau Alpa says straight away, he's less conciliatory today. And he says, I've come to tell you to return everything you've stolen since you entered my kingdom. I mean, clearly I think he's getting gearing up for a fight. And Valverde, who must have been very nervous, begins to recite something.
瓦尔韦德以对阿塔瓦尔帕说，你想进来和弗朗西斯科·皮萨罗共进晚餐吗开始。这显然是一个让他离开部下的策略。阿塔瓦尔帕说，不。阿塔瓦尔帕立刻说，他今天没那么和解。他说，我来告诉你们，归还你们进入我的王国以来偷走的一切。我是说，显然我认为他正在为战斗做准备。而瓦尔韦德，他一定非常紧张，开始背诵一些东西。
and the interpreter is translating all the time. And Valverdi says, I'm a minister of Christ, and he starts gabbling about the history of the world. Jesus came into the world, crucified to save sinners. My king, Charles V, that sent me to tell you all about this. You must accept Christ as your master in heaven. You must accept my king, Charles V, as your master on earth. You must become his vassal.
翻译一直在翻译。瓦尔韦德说，我是基督的牧师，他开始喋喋不休地讲世界历史。耶稣来到世上，被钉死在十字架上以拯救罪人。我的国王，查理五世，派我来告诉你们这一切。你们必须接受基督作为你们在天上的主。你们必须接受我的国王，查理五世，作为你们在地球上的主。你们必须成为他的附庸。
You must give up your gods. And if you don't, quote, if you refuse and seek to resist, then you and all your people will be destroyed, just as the Pharaoh of old and all his host perished in the Red Sea. I mean, if the translator is interpreting all this to Atta Walpa, Atta Welper must have been listening to this thinking,
你们必须放弃你们的神。如果你们不这样做，引用，如果你们拒绝并试图反抗，那么你们和你们所有的人民都将被毁灭，就像古代的法老和他的所有军队在红海中灭亡一样。我是说，如果翻译把这一切都翻译给阿塔瓦尔帕，阿塔瓦尔帕一定在听着这些想，
what is this? I can't believe he said that. Yeah, well, of course, it just seems extraordinary. But it's signaling how the Spaniards will cast the downfall of Atta Walper, right? Of course, of course. Now, I think what Valverdi is doing, I think what a lot of historians think what Valverdi is doing, is he is reciting a version of the requirement, which is this bizarre legal document we mentioned
这是什么？我不敢相信他说了这些。是的，好吧，这看起来确实非同寻常。但这标志着西班牙人将如何塑造阿塔瓦尔帕的垮台，对吧？当然，当然。现在，我认为瓦尔韦德正在做的是，我认为很多历史学家认为瓦尔韦德正在做的是，他正在背诵《要求书》的一个版本，这是我们提到的那个奇怪的法律文件
already that since 1513, Spanish captains are legally bound to read out to the peoples of the Americas before they kill them. Now, even at the time when the Council of Castile approved this, lots of Spaniards said, are you mad? You're going to read this out to people before you attack them. I mean, expect them to understand it. And of course, the interpreters are useless. in Chiamauga. So they're kind of mistranslating things. And Atta Welper, listening to this must have just thought, what? gibberish.
自1513年以来，西班牙船长在杀害美洲原住民之前，法律上必须向他们宣读一份文件。即使在卡斯蒂利亚议会批准这项规定时，许多西班牙人也说：你们疯了吗？在攻击他们之前还要读这个？你们指望他们能听懂吗？当然，在卡哈马卡，翻译人员根本没用，他们翻译得一塌糊涂。阿塔瓦尔帕听着这些，一定觉得这简直是胡言乱语。
Yeah. Now, Atta Welper is looking, confused, angry, impatient. And Valverde says, perhaps you'd like to have a look at my prayer book. Making chat. Small talk. Atta Welper, to stress, has never seen a book before or writing of any kind. No, because he's only got cords with knots in, hasn't he? we're not. Valverdi gives him the book and it's one of those books that it must have like a buckle
是的。现在，阿塔瓦尔帕看起来既困惑又愤怒，还很不耐烦。瓦尔韦德说：也许你想看看我的祈祷书？试图闲聊。阿塔瓦尔帕要强调的是，他以前从未见过书或任何形式的文字。因为他只有结绳记事，对吧？瓦尔韦德把书递给他，那是一本带有扣环的书。
or a clip or a lock or something like that on it. And Atta Welper tries to open it and he can't open it. He's never seen an object like this. And Valverdi reaches out to help him. Attawelper hits him contemptuously, manages to open the book and stares at it and we are told he looked with great interest at the construction of the book, the sort of what it was. But obviously, he doesn't know that these symbols are words or that there's a story or that they're prayers or whatever. It's just madness to him. Now, what happens next is unclear. Some people say Attauilpa threw the book down in the dust and with contempt. Some say that actually Valverdi took the book back and dropped it or dropped it while handing it to him or something like this. Anyway, at some point,
或者夹子、锁之类的东西。阿塔瓦尔帕试图打开它，却打不开。他从未见过这样的东西。瓦尔韦德伸手去帮他，阿塔瓦尔帕轻蔑地拍开他的手，设法打开了书，盯着它看。据记载，他饶有兴趣地观察书的构造，研究那是什么东西。但显然，他不知道这些符号是文字，也不知道里面有故事或祈祷文之类的东西。对他来说，这简直是疯了。接下来发生了什么还不清楚。有人说阿塔瓦尔帕轻蔑地把书扔进了尘土里。也有人说，其实是瓦尔韦德拿回书时，或者在递给他时掉在了地上。总之，在某个时刻，
the book ends up on the ground in the dust, and this is the pretext that the Spanish need. When the book falls, Attaualpa shouts something to his own men, but Valverde is already running back to the barracks, and he's shouting to Bizarro. Come out, come out, Christians, the dogs have rejected the word of God, that proud dog has thrown my book of holy law to the ground. He has become a Lucifer, all words to that effect. That is the trigger for Pedro de Candia on the platform to fire his gun. into the crowd at the Inkers. At the Inkers. Now, of course, the Inkers must have seen the guns,
书掉在了尘土里，这就是西班牙人需要的借口。书一落地，阿塔瓦尔帕就向他的人喊了些什么，但瓦尔韦德已经跑回营房，向皮萨罗大喊：出来，出来，基督徒们，这些狗拒绝了上帝的话语，那只傲慢的狗把我的圣法书扔到了地上。他已经成了路西法，诸如此类的话。这就是佩德罗·德·坎迪亚在平台上向印加人群开枪的信号。向印加人开枪。当然，印加人一定看到了枪，
but they didn't know what they were. So what a shock that is. Suddenly the guns, there's a huge, you know, bang, bang, bang. The Inkers are reeling in the crowd. Then Pedro de Kandir says, sound the trumpets. The trumpets blasts. So there's a sort of sensory overload. And it's at that point that the Spanish horsemen
但他们不知道那是什么。所以那真是太令人震惊了。突然间，枪声大作，砰、砰、砰。印加人群在人群中摇晃。然后佩德罗·德·坎迪亚说：吹响号角。号角声响起。这是一种感官过载。就在那一刻，西班牙骑兵
burst out of the barracks on their horses. They've got their swords drawn. They're all screaming, Santiago, Santiago. which is their kind of walk rye. And it's very like the bit at the end of the two towers, Helms deep, when the riders are Rohan kind of burst out of the fortress, cutting a sway through the orcs. This is the scene in the square.
骑着马从营房里冲了出来。他们拔出剑，大喊着：圣地亚哥，圣地亚哥。这是他们的战吼。这非常像《指环王：双塔奇兵》中圣盔谷的那一幕，当洛汗骑兵冲出堡垒，在半兽人中杀出一条血路。这就是广场上的场景。
So the Spanish have tied bells and rattles to their horses' bridles to make the maximum possible noise. And the Inkers, of course, who are not used to horses, who are frightened of horses. Straight away, they're in total chaos. They're screaming. They're running everywhere. They're stampeding and crushing each other.
西班牙人在马的缰绳上系了铃铛和拨浪鼓，以制造最大的噪音。而印加人当然不习惯马，他们害怕马。瞬间，他们陷入了彻底的混乱。他们尖叫着，四处奔逃。他们惊慌失措，互相践踏。
Well, it's come as a complete surprise, right? Total surprise. The Spanish have come from nowhere. Guns, horses, this is stuff they've never seen before. The swords are flashing. The Inkers are slipping and falling everywhere. There's bodies piling up. There's blood everywhere.
这完全是个意外，对吧？彻底的意外。西班牙人从天而降。枪支、马匹，这些都是他们从未见过的东西。剑光闪烁。印加人到处滑倒摔倒。尸体堆积如山。到处都是血。
People are literally suffocating each other in the crush and the carnage. And when they get to the ends, to the gates, to the ways out of the square, Pizarres, other men are there, swords drawn to block them. Now, some of the Inca's managed to break through a low wall. and to get out of the square into the fields beyond. So thousands of people start streaming out into the fields. But the Spanish horsemen are following them out and the captains are shouting, and I quote,
人们在拥挤和屠杀中窒息而死。当他们到达广场的尽头、出口时，皮萨罗的其他手下已经在那里，拔出剑挡住去路。一些印加人设法冲破了一堵矮墙，逃出了广场，进入了外面的田野。成千上万的人开始涌向田野。但西班牙骑兵追了出去，队长们大喊着，我引用：
ride them down, don't let any of them escape. And this is a scene of utter slaughter. The cavalry riding them down one by one, without mercy, cutting them down. The whole thing takes two hours and it is a complete and utter walkover. The Wikipedia entry calls it the Battle of Cayamaca. But it's not a battle.
把他们踩在马下，一个也不要放过。这是一场彻底的屠杀。骑兵一个接一个地追杀他们，毫不留情地砍杀。整个过程持续了两个小时，这是一场彻底的单方面碾压。维基百科条目称之为卡哈马卡战役。但这根本不是战役。
But it's not a battle. It's a complete massacre. So Spanish sources themselves said, you know, once the cavalry had done their work and then burst out following the people who were running away, the foot soldiers went into the square and they put every single person there to the sword. During all this, no Indian even raised a weapon against a Spaniard. Attawalpa's nephew, Titu Kuzi, who wrote his own version of a sword. events long time afterwards said it was said that the Spanish went about their business like slaughter men with cattle just killing them grimly methodically without any pity. I mean that metaphor it shows how long after it must have been for an Inker to come up
但这根本不是战役。这是一场彻底的屠杀。西班牙人自己的记载也说，一旦骑兵完成了他们的工作，冲出去追赶逃跑的人，步兵就进入广场，把那里剩下的每一个人都处决了。在此期间，没有一个印第安人对西班牙人举起过武器。阿塔瓦尔帕的侄子蒂图·库西在很久之后写下了自己的版本，他说，据说西班牙人像屠夫对待牲畜一样行事，冷酷而有条不紊地杀戮，没有任何怜悯。那个比喻说明了印加人过了多久才想出
with that. Exactly. Yeah. John Heming in his brilliant book, The Conquest of the Inkers said, you know, how do you know how many people died somewhere between 2 and 8,000, even if you take a kind of lower estimate. Each Spaniard must have killed probably 10, 12, 14, 15 Peruvians each. I mean, there's a lot of bloodshed. It's a dreadful, dreadful story. And among the people who are killed, of course, at Atta Welper's elite, his stewards, his servants, his friends, his counsellors, his chief
那个词。没错。约翰·海明在他那本出色的《征服印加》一书中说，你怎么知道死了多少人？大约在2000到8000人之间，即使按较低的估计。每个西班牙人可能杀死了10、12、14、15个秘鲁人。这真是血流成河。这是一个极其可怕的故事。当然，在被杀的人中，有阿塔瓦尔帕的精英、管家、仆人、朋友、顾问、首席
advisors, his chief nobleman, his chief captains, all of these people who would have been with him, who would never have, they would never have thought that anything like this could happen. So it is a complete decapitation. Yeah, complete catastrophe for the Inca state. And Dominica, I have to ask, what about the emperor? Well, so right at the beginning, Pizarro and his men had made straight for the litter. And they'd been shouting Santiago as well. They hacked their way through the crowd.
顾问、首席贵族、首席队长，所有这些一直陪伴他的人，他们从未想过会发生这样的事。所以这是一次彻底的斩首。是的，对印加国家来说是一场彻底的灾难。多米尼卡，我必须问，皇帝怎么样了？嗯，就在一开始，皮萨罗和他的手下就直奔轿子而去。他们也一直在喊圣地亚哥。他们从人群中杀出一条路。
And Pizarro, were told, grabbed hold of Attawelper's left arm. But he couldn't pull him out of the litter, which of course has been held up quite high. And loads of Inca's are clinging to the litter to stop them taking the emperor. And the Spanish, I mean, a hideous scene, are literally hacking at the Inca's arms, cutting off their hands, cutting off their arms in an attempt to get the litter down. But more Inca's rushing around to protect him. Eventually, one of the Spaniards, Miguel de Estete, who wrote a really good memoir about all this, he pulled the crown off Attau'alpa's head, and then he slashed at Attauelper with his knife,
据记载，皮萨罗抓住了阿塔瓦尔帕的左臂。但他无法把他从轿子里拉出来，轿子当然被抬得很高。许多印加人紧紧抓住轿子，阻止他们带走皇帝。西班牙人，真是可怕的场景，简直是在砍断印加人的手臂，砍掉他们的手，砍掉他们的胳膊，试图把轿子弄下来。但更多的印加人冲过来保护他。最终，其中一名西班牙人米格尔·德·埃斯特特，他写了一本关于这一切的非常好的回忆录，他摘下了阿塔瓦尔帕头上的王冠，然后用刀砍向阿塔瓦尔帕，
and Pizarro shouted, no, don't kill him. And he put his hand in the way. So his own man cut his hand, which is now dripping with blood. Eventually in the chaos, seven or eight, Spaniards managed to kind of weigh down one side of the litter,
皮萨罗大喊：不，别杀他。他把手挡在中间。所以他自己的手下砍伤了他的手，现在正滴着血。最终在混乱中，七八个西班牙人设法压住轿子的一侧，
and they dragged Attaweb out, and they bundled him away through the chaos towards the temple of the sun. And they locked him in this temple while the rest of their comrades went about their murderous work in the square. And then when the fighting
他们把阿塔瓦尔帕拖了出来，在混乱中把他带向太阳神庙。他们把他锁在这座神庙里，而他们的同伴则在广场上进行着杀戮。当战斗
had totally died down, they brought him out again. They dragged him to one of the barracks. He's covered with you know, blood, his clothes are ragged, all of that. They give him new clothes. Are they European clothes? That I don't know, actually.
完全平息后，他们又把他带了出来。他们把他拖到其中一个营房。他浑身是血，衣服破烂不堪，诸如此类。他们给了他新衣服。是欧洲服装吗？这个我倒不知道。
It just says new clothes. I'm guessing maybe European clothes. And then they bring him in to see Pizarro, who like a Bond villain, set up... We meet again, Mr Atta Walpa. Set up with a table and chairs for dinner. Actually, it's interesting, the table and chairs. The Inkers didn't eat with the table and chairs.
只说是新衣服。我猜可能是欧洲服装。然后他们带他去见皮萨罗，皮萨罗像个邦德电影里的反派一样，摆好了……我们又见面了，阿塔瓦尔帕先生。摆好了桌椅准备吃晚餐。其实，桌椅很有趣。印加人不用桌椅吃饭。
So are we led to believe that the... the Spanish had brought a table and chairs with them? I mean, yeah, that sounds improbable. It's a mad detail, but so much of this story is mad. And actually, it's going to get madder. Because Attau Alper sits down to dinner with Pizarro, surrounded by Spanish guards and servants. As John Heming says in his brilliant book, what a weird scene. The Spaniards are caked in blood and sweat.
所以我们要相信……西班牙人随身带着桌椅吗？嗯，这听起来不太可能。这是一个疯狂的细节，但这个故事的很多部分都很疯狂。而且实际上，它会变得更疯狂。因为阿塔瓦尔帕和皮萨罗坐下来吃晚餐，周围是西班牙卫兵和仆人。正如约翰·海明在他那本出色的书中说的，多么奇怪的场景。西班牙人身上沾满了血和汗。
And Pizarro is having dinner. And Attaweper is sitting there, I mean, completely traumatized, right? Do we know what they're eating? I don't know a guinea pig, surely. Guinea pig? Guinea pig and sweet potatoes. And then, if that's not weird enough, Pizarro says a sentence that I don't think anyone and listen to this will expect, you'll sleep with me tonight.
皮萨罗正在吃晚餐。阿塔瓦尔帕坐在那里，完全受到了创伤，对吧？我们知道他们吃什么吗？我不知道，肯定是豚鼠。豚鼠？豚鼠和红薯。然后，如果这还不够奇怪，皮萨罗说了一句我想在座的各位都不会预料到的话：你今晚和我睡。
This is the beginning of a beautiful friendship. Because basically he says to the servants, make up a mattress for the emperor, he will sleep with me, next to me, we will sleep side by side. And so you have this incredible scene, the most powerful man in South America, bedding down for the night right next to this illegitimate, illiterate Spanish veteran who was just pulled off one of the most amazing coups in all history. Do you think either of them get any sleep? I see Pizarro as a snorer, to be honest, so I think it's a tough night for Atta Welper. Night falls over Kiamauga. Outside the city in their camp, the Inca army is just in disbelief
这是一段美好友谊的开始。因为他基本上对仆人说：给皇帝铺个床垫，他要和我睡，在我旁边，我们要并排睡。于是就有了这个不可思议的场景，南美洲最有权势的人，竟然和一个刚策划了历史上最惊人政变之一的、文盲的西班牙老兵并排躺下睡觉。你认为他们俩能睡着吗？老实说，我觉得皮萨罗是个打呼噜的人，所以我认为这对阿塔瓦尔帕来说是个难熬的夜晚。夜幕降临卡哈马卡。在城外的营地里，印加军队简直不敢相信
of what's happened. In the square, the carrion crows are feasting on the bodies of the dead. And in Pizarro's quarters here and Attauilipra lying, you know, a few inches away from each other with Spanish guards by the door. It has been one of the most incredible days in history. One chronicler said, truly it was not accomplished by our own forces. For the worst, so few of us, it was by the grace of God. But of course, it wasn't really the grace of God. It was the recklessness, the ingenuity, the daring of Pizarro and the brutality of the conquistadors that had brought all this about. And I suppose the complete miscomprehension
发生了什么。在广场上，食腐乌鸦正在享用死者的尸体。而在皮萨罗的住处，阿塔瓦尔帕躺在离他几英寸远的地方，门口有西班牙卫兵守着。这是历史上最不可思议的日子之一。一位编年史家说：这确实不是靠我们自己的力量完成的。因为我们人太少了，这是上帝的恩典。但当然，这并不是真正的上帝恩典。是皮萨罗的鲁莽、独创性、胆识以及征服者的残暴才导致了这一切。我想还有完全的误解，
that Attawalpa had of what he was up against. I mean, cruel and brutal, though he is as well. Yeah, of course. I mean, my heart doesn't bleed for Atalpa, but what happened to the Inca's in that square is still pretty brutal, pretty horrible. But the story, of course, isn't over because there are still only 168 Spaniards and they are still surrounded by tens of thousands of Inca warriors and they're still at the heart of a country of more than 10 million people, you know, not necessarily very friendly to them. So Pizarro now has some choices to make. And we will soon find out what his plan is and what he has in mind for Attawelper, Emperor of the Inca's, but we won't find out until the next episode. So members of the Rested History Club can hear that episode right now.
阿塔瓦尔帕对他所面对的东西一无所知。我的意思是，虽然他也很残忍。是的，当然。我的心不会为阿塔瓦尔帕流血，但印加人在那个广场上的遭遇仍然非常残酷，非常可怕。但故事当然还没有结束，因为仍然只有168名西班牙人，他们仍然被成千上万的印加战士包围着，而且他们仍然身处一个拥有超过1000万人口的国家的心脏地带，这些人未必对他们很友好。所以皮萨罗现在必须做出一些选择。我们很快就会知道他的计划是什么，以及他对印加皇帝阿塔瓦尔帕有什么打算，但我们得等到下一集才能知道。所以休息历史俱乐部的成员现在就可以听到那一集了。
And a massive excitement, they will be able to get the next three episodes on Thursday. and if you are not a member of The Restis History Club, not a member of our happy band of Conquistadors, and you would like to join them, then head to The Restis History.com to sign up. But for now, adios. Adios. Troy, the Odyssey, the Iliad,
而且非常令人兴奋的是，他们将在周四获得接下来的三集。如果你不是休息历史俱乐部的成员，不是我们快乐的征服者乐队的一员，并且你想加入他们，那么请前往TheRestisHistory.com注册。但现在，再见。再见。特洛伊，奥德赛，伊利亚特，
all of these great ancient epics depict a monumental claps that destroyed the interconnected empires of 3,000 years ago. And to understand the Bronze Age apocalypse that Homer wrote about 400 years after it happened, subscribe to Empire, world history, a fellow gollhanger podcast where we are deep diving into the biggest imperial collapse in ancient history. To get a flavour of the series, here is a clip from our episode with none other than Stephen Fry. It is one of my favourite subjects, the story of the Greeks and the Siege of Troy and Odysseus's return home, of course.
所有这些伟大的古代史诗都描绘了一场摧毁了3000年前相互关联的帝国的巨大崩溃。要了解荷马在事件发生400年后所写的青铜时代大崩溃，请订阅《帝国》，这是一档世界历史节目，也是Gollhanger旗下的播客，我们正在深入探讨古代历史上最大的帝国崩溃。为了让你对这个系列有个了解，这里有一段我们与斯蒂芬·弗莱的节目片段。这是我最喜欢的主题之一，关于希腊人的故事，特洛伊围城战，当然还有奥德修斯的回家之路。
I say Greeks. Homer called them the Achaeans, the Danians, the Argyves. the word Greeks is a much later one, but it refers really to the Mycenaeans, a warrior aristocracy essentially, obsessed with honor and reputation that would give them an eternal glory, a Cleos, as they call it. It's the Cleos that's in the name of so many Greeks, you know, Cleopatra and all the sort of tea, you know, all the Cleese, Heracles, who's Hercules, you know, Herra's Glory. He was actually named Heracles because she hated him because. he was a love child of Zeus, and she never liked Zeus's love child, her husband, her
我说希腊人。荷马称他们为阿凯亚人、达南人、阿耳戈斯人。希腊人这个词是后来才有的，但它实际上指的是迈锡尼人，本质上是一个战士贵族阶层，痴迷于荣誉和声誉，这会给他们带来永恒的荣耀，也就是他们所说的克莱奥斯。很多希腊人的名字里都有克莱奥斯，你知道，克利奥帕特拉，还有所有那些，你知道，所有的克莱斯，赫拉克勒斯，也就是赫丘利，你知道，赫拉的荣耀。他之所以被命名为赫拉克勒斯，是因为她恨他，因为他是宙斯的私生子，她从来不喜欢宙斯的私生子，她的丈夫，她那
errant husband. And so as an attempt to placate her, Tariasius, because he was born in Thebes, suggested that he changed his name, as a baby, this was, to Heracles, the glory of Heron. It didn't help much. It didn't help at all. And then Athena even put her on Hera's breast when Hero was asleep, because it would bond them if he suckled her milk. But she woke and saw it and tossed him away, and her breast milk spread across
不忠的丈夫。为了安抚她，提瑞西阿斯，因为他出生在底比斯，建议他改名，这是在他还是婴儿的时候，改为赫拉克勒斯，赫拉的荣耀。这没起多大作用。一点用都没有。然后雅典娜甚至在赫拉睡觉时把赫拉克勒斯放在了赫拉的胸口，因为如果他吮吸她的乳汁，他们就会建立联系。但她醒来看到这一幕，把他扔开了，她的乳汁洒满了
the sky to form the Milky Way. I didn't know that story. Because galaxy, of course, is from the Greek for milk, galactic, as in lactic. So the chocolate makers are right. Anyway, this is completely separate. Lovely. Cleos. Keep going.
天空，形成了银河。我不知道那个故事。因为银河，当然，来自希腊语中的牛奶，银河系的，就像乳酸一样。所以巧克力制造商是对的。总之，这完全是另一回事。可爱。克莱奥斯。继续。
Don't stop. Well, we really hope you enjoyed that clip. Here more on the Bronze Age apocalypse and how it shaped the ancient Greek epics. Just subscribe to Empire, wherever you get your podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
别停。好吧，我们真的希望你喜欢那个片段。想了解更多关于青铜时代大崩溃以及它如何塑造了古希腊史诗的内容，请订阅《帝国》，无论你在哪里收听播客。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。